commencement c'est c'est reparti je
vérifier comme d'hab que tout soit bien
parti justement ça m'a l'air pas mal
mais on est reparti on est reparti pour
du très très lourd les amis on est
reparti produit très très très lourd
parce que c'est très lourd les amis
c'est la troisième fois qu'on va suivre
le même tournoi ensemble on entendra
encore un la semaine prochaine bien
évidemment parce que quand même il faut
pas exagérer les bonnes choses ne
doivent pas avoir une fin et donc on va
on va en faire quatre d'affilée la tse
speech est extraordinaire c'est
extraordinaire donc on va re suivre du
coup ça recommence du début on sait
toujours pas quel match suivre à temps
et ça c'est cool parce que je me suis
laissée l'alertent à aimer c'est pas la
mienne ça c'est pas bon c'est pas bon je
vérifier avec le téléphone en fait c'est
bien démarré ce sera mieux
ah bon je mette l'hostis mien pourra
pour ça je peux le faire que après avoir
démarré un live à taq taq taq
et hop c'est parti ouais ça c'est bien
joué j'espère que ça vous intéressera de
suivre ce tournoi je sais pas à quel
point c'est intéressant un salut à zig
jeu
j'ai malheureusement dû mal à avouer ip
là j'ai du mal à moto a ripé en fait
j'ai du mal à moto à bp c'est vrai que
déjà premier n'était pas très
intéressant le deuxième encore moins à
c'est le troisième sur la même chose
chaque semaine c'est c'est compliqué
j'ai vraiment du mal à comprendre
comprendre l'intérêt mais mais c'est
comme ça alors c'est plus les
demi-finales d'ailleurs j'avais laissé
les demi finales c'est bel et bien le
premier tour
le retour du premier tour mais je
n'arrive honnêtement pas à comprendre
comment un format pareil a pu être
appuyé a pu être fait honnêtement c'est
c'est terrible c'est terrible c'est quoi
la source du fonds reçus du format en
fait ils jouent quatre fois d'affilée le
même tournoi week frigide donc c'est
terrible ça dure chaque tournoi dure
cinq jours et c'est un éternel
recommencement du début en fait donc
c'est certes terrible quoi c'est c'est
comme si tu jouer un tour à tennis à 8
et que tu recommences et tous les lundis
avec les mêmes les mêmes joueurs le même
tournoi c'est terrible c'est très long
chez match dure 1h40 chacun 1h45 3h30 du
coup par jour ce qui joua il vous de
jouer les matchs à la suite et c'est
vraiment c'est vraiment difficile de
rester à ip de et de garder un intérêt à
la halle pour pour la compétition le
premier set et ça allait le deuxième
c'était dur là le troisième je vous
avoue que je sais même pas comment
du coup j'étais site a planté la qualif
non non c'est les mêmes joueurs qui
recommence de toute façon et c'est que
sur quatre semaines et ça changerait en
fait c'est pas une saison c'est un truc
sur quatre semaines c'est le même toit
qui recommence et il n'y a pas vraiment
de finalité en fait c'est 4 fois le même
tournoi d'affilée c'est tout en fait
sans finalité spéciale donc c'est juste
le nouveau le même ton maquis qui
recommence quoi ni plus ni moins c'est
vrai que c'est un peu c'est un peu
spécial devrait soulager la numéro un
mondiale ifan en espérant qu'elles
qu'elles fassent mieux dans ce tournoi
pour elle ça va être un peu dommage mais
du coup tu peux gagner quatre fois ouais
ça tu peux gagner quatre forêts et sarah
saran lors en deuxième partie de journée
floby bieber on regardera sahara non
mais oui c'est pas ce pad se passe passe
pas facile de rester coi
lorsque l'effort à la smash bros etc un
winner bracket un loser bracket ça c'est
pas mal si tu perds tu passes en loser
bracket sujet des losers tu peux quand
même tenté une première place en finale
contre le gagnant du winner bracket
bah en fait photo avec le loser bracket
jeu j'aime bien les losers bracket mais
que s'ils te permettent de re rentrer
dans la compétition
genre tu prends 12 joueurs
thaci gagnant et après tu refais un
loser bracket à côté qui peut plus te
permettre de rentrer ou quoi mais je
veux pas que le loser bracket te ramène
en finale quoi parce que c'est ces bêtes
voit les poules de quatre avec deux
personnes qui pias qui passe ouais ça ça
peut être pas mal mais juste cela
recommence et 4 fois le même tournoi
c'est terrible parce que du coup le le
truc qui dure un mois pendant un mois
talent dans la même compétition qui
recommence éternellement je ne sais pas
à quelle part moi ça me parait inhumain
de rester hype et pour le truc pendant
tout le temps parce qu'il n'ya même pas
d'augmentation au rail pas en fait
c'est ça le truc entre guillemets il n'y
a même pas de variété dans le format la
clotte truc quand tim ou couasnon
week-end wilfried ya pas de variétés en
fait c'est c'est la même chose en fait
et en fait c'était la même chose quatre
jours de suite ce serait une chose pas
si si la compétition durera à chaque
fois un jour et qu'on l'a joué quatre
fois en fait est qu'après par après il
faut un petit classement à la fin de qui
a marqué le plus de points mais ça
pourrait être cool en soi mais là le
truc c'est que c'est à chaque fois la
compétition dure une semaine quoi ce
terrible c'est terrible cette série fico
essaye de saipem et ça va pas être
facile sans aucun relief 4 jouer essayer
de faire de notre mieux
on l'a les noirs une position correcte
j'ai l'impression qu'ils ont pris le
mille cavaliers sur f 4g oublie de faire
un petit truc de préparation encore
mélissa ça devient de plus en plus dur
quoi
enfin je rigole on rigole et c'est pas
très drôle c'est pas très drôle on va
voir au moins si on a peut-être un match
serré de façon on va essayer de suivre
un peu les quatre matches de loin et
puis et puis on verra ce que ça donne
on peut regarder les parties et puis on
verra ce que ça donne
qu'est ce qui arrive en d5 la dette elle
peut prendre en dessin quelle force à
reprendre avec un pion s'agir h ce sera
une bonne nouvelle ça lui a donc à pâte
à foin à enlever qu'à 100 m'attaque je
suis de passage sera intéressant non je
dois dire la vérité pas vraiment est-ce
que je suivais le che ce qu'ils veulent
je pense pas max je pense pas enfin en
tout cas pas dès le premier tour pas
tous les matches pas tous les matches
mais peut-être en partir d'une demi
finale ou quoi mais je vais parce je
vais pas je vais pas tenir en fait
passer une barre toi je suis pas là de
toute façon leur premier match et samedi
je suis pas donc non non je serai pas je
suivrai pas je serai pas le match de
marco ça c'est sûr peut-être à partir
des demi-finales ou quoi mais pas le
premier match
j'aurais pu le faire si j'avais pas
suivi ce truc là qu'on sûrement en ce
moment j'aurais pu m'arranger mais
problème c'est que doit aller chercher
borie souka et du cou et du coup je pars
samedi il aurait fallu que je sois
remplacé pour ce truc là
voilà ça pour les noirs en vrai hein
parce qu'elle a repris 2 s'est du coup
il ya plus problème du pion arriérés
elle va pouvoir jouer avec f5 iata
kallel dame
jude law ou pas pas un bon premier début
de partie de la numéro un mondiale
mais du coup le taf 5
mais du coup peut-être f5 vert
paraît intéressante c'est fou j'ai cinq
sets par malaucène losc et h3 échec au
passage découverte
bref 5 qui va arriver plutôt bien
bonjour si ce match est cool jour je
rajouterais les caméras un peu plus tard
f5 va arriver
bon on va voir en voir comment elle joue
mais si tu es adamence et royal à tour
qui arrive ans et huit en face ouais ça
a l'air chiant à roue à chien on peut
même faire cavaler h3 mon x 5 elle
contre attaque la dame peut juste la
bouger 1res compare même en f 6 h 6 pour
se préparer à attaquer le roi ça paraît
logique fait un f6 y avait peut-être des
bonus avec des cavaliers h3 qui
l'attaqué le fou mais bon cette logique
aussi un peu envoyez un fou et 5 pour
attaquer la tour eiffe un protégé
bessette et après on voyait fait 5 ou
envoyer f5 direct to b 5 jouer l attaque
la tour
ça se passe clairement très bien pour
les noirs en plus la colonne s'est elle
peut peut-être cela gagner puisque à
l'oeuf ou g5 qui l'a qui contrôle la
casse c'est un voilage en retour ces
huit ça peut peut être un coup à f/5
peut être un coup laissé la tour venir
ans et 7 et se fixer sur l' attaque
peut-être f5 quand même hein faut
commencer à envoyer rentrée en attaque
je suis bloqué ok mama fesses étaient
bloqués dans les villes donc je disais
quoi j'ai des voix soit 8,5 soit soit f5
soit elle fait damer fisma n'aurait donc
ça prouve bien qu'elle a perdu en temps
quand même et salluste hasek
ça prouve bien qu'elle a perdu un temps
dan f6 elle veut elle veut du cavalier
h3 peut-être mais moqué h trois rois h1
et il n'ya pas cavalli pro f 2 puisque
s'est défendu mon tour ces deux camps
mais mes mains et afu des tannants foot
est roi c'est pas grand chose pendant
peut-être damage 6 ou d'alger 6 alors
dame gses peut-être plutôt comme ça tu
menaces ou des 3 es tu prépares f5 sur
une collecte dame celle ci dessous des 3
tu pourrais de gagner depuis on a eu
quatre dames justice a vraiment la tête
d'un bon coup m6 à la tête d'un super
coup peut-être même fou des trois dames
j'ai si c'est encore mieux
bien très bien joué de la part de moules
joue vraiment bien la boule jaune
tours
qui est peut-être f5 maintenant un fou
des huit as et elle veut cavale et h3
qui est pro f 2 parce que la dame
protégera plus qu'elle s'ajoute pas mal
ça joue pas mal
elle joue vraiment bien la bouc joue le
trouve je trouve qu'elle fait vraiment
une très bonne partie ouais maintenant
le faire flasher 4 j'imagine elle
revient à si elle prend nul c'est
dommage elle doit faire flasher 4 elle
doit jouer fou h4 absolument ouais bien
joué protéger son cavalier elle va
préparer la prison ou quatre ballons
c'est dur pour pourri fans là qui va
attaquer par une défaite contre contre
le moule à mon avis c'est pas encore
fait quoi que ce n'est pas encore fait
tour 3 belle défense à l'attaqué
le foot est roi et karelia je crois
cavaliers f2 ça fait gagner du temps et
fou bessin qu'elle pourra refaire les
prêts moov'in tu as toujours pas mal ça
pour gagner du temps
donc l afo faire gaffe quand même à
elles gagnent autant bêtement caillage 3
le cookie tu observes fins héros un bouc
joue qui a vraiment dominé la première
c'est bien joué
maintenant à zéro ou iphone qui a qui a
jamais jamais été mieux et qui réfléchit
déjà à près de 4 c 5 kf3 le fait des six
à avoir des quatre elle ouvre une
sicilienne une sirène ouverte qui a ici
sur leur cas et c3 et la caisse qu'elle
va jouer oui fans à 6 d'accord une âge
d'or fouet 3,6 f3 donc un structure type
chef dingue ça va attaquer ou alors si
oui fans réussi à revenir dans le match
mais mes joues qui peut il ya déjà une
balle de break entre guillemets qui
pourrait prendre deux points d'avance en
ce début de match ce qui ce qui serait
ce qui serait déjà un petit écart 1 ce
qui serait déjà un petit écart on va
voir si elle y arrive
des cinq jouer elle elle s'en prend au
centre avec les noirs ont d'ailleurs
voir quoique toujours gagnante est de
même des caraïbes 4 pions prend
cavaliers prend 1,6 puis on prend qu'à
rallier prend aux cavaliers g6 ça ça
peut ça peut être une idée ça pour les
blancs c'est un sacrifice évidemment
mais la dame doit l'en à 5 pour garder
le contrôle de ses 7es pas cependant une
fourchette et ça peut continuer parfois
f4 ça peut être extrêmement dangereux ça
genre wife's est fou c'est 4 on peut se
faire complètement découper il faut être
très vigilant avec ce genre de deux
variantes
on va voir comment ça se passe dans la
partie d'anjou qui réfléchit pour le
moment à l'est où il fallait aussi fan
car il ya quatre ça se regarde c'est sûr
à quoi doit penser moulin qui avait les
f4 il ya aussi aux 5 à regarder mais sur
quoi il peut y avoir des cavaliers s'est
si souvent des cavaliers de six parfois
dames c'est cette ici par exemple qu on
prend qui on prend fou prend f4 fou des
six tours 1
tout ça ça peut ça peut ça peut être des
choses jouable après avoir un elle a
fait cavalier g3 plus timides fou
bessède joué par les noirs
donc elle renforce avec le fonds en
baisse est la pression sur le pion aux 4
elle protège le pion des 5
bon ça joue un sage ou toi est-ce
qu'elle va continuer h 4 g 5
j'en prends cavaliers prend mais là le
cavalier rebondit bien elle veut
peut-être s'en prendre aux footeux 3 à
mettre le fond ces cinq jours les cases
noires après je pense c'est pas du tout
ce qu'elle voulait réaliser avec les
blancs mais ça s'est passé comme ça
dames c'est cette fougue et 3 est ce
qu'elle va faire fou à 4 après pour
essayer de mettre la pression sur le roi
mais les nappes ont tous joué gros rock
aussi un d'ailleurs au cas où
pas sûr que les blancs réussissent à
attaquer facilement
bon je sais pas à quel point c'est mieux
pour les noirs si ça les mêmes positions
est vraiment compliqué ça donne
l'impression quand même ce qui a valu en
dessin qui fait quand même mal prendre
ce fou et 3 ça semble être un problème
mais bon on va bien voir prendre deux
trois et b3 peut être un supprimer les
deux fous et après m'être le foie en c5
et rockets c'est une option clairement
c'est très clairement une option à voir
on va voir comment comment elle décide
de faire avec les noirs comme elle
procède perd de vue paraît quand même
très fort titien va-t-elle prendre de
ces avec les blancs je prends du
cavalier lui dsk vous prendre de sévères
tour c'est un essayer de regagner un peu
des tempos mais qui avait pris à trois
dames 33 et peut-être des a5 maintenant
qu'ils vont re des fous hausse est aussi
un coup un vêtement pour mettre le fond
à m6 qui défendra le roi et qui
attaquera le roi blanc risque elle prend
la décision de jouer à cache-cache 4l
peut pas y aller car il est en l'air
donc escale mais le quart ayant h 5 e
cat way pour contrôler un peu les cases
il va y avoir rock peut-être ici et tour
c'est 8 à 5 à 4 en gros c'est le plan
avec les blancs il va falloir essayer de
faire h4 g5 mais les fous sont
largement supérieurs aux cavaliers ici
dans une position aussi ouverte où là il
ya énormément de travaux à côté de chez
moi on va voir ce que ça donne
si ça se calme pas je vais être obligé
de fermer la fenêtre que jouer vite et
ce qui fait hyper chaud et que l'âge
mais pas de clim ce que ça me rend ça me
rend malade la crim donc j'évite mais là
je sais pas ce qu'ils font j'ai
l'impression que qu'ils sont en train de
refaire la ville
on ne sait pas c'est pas coincé pour
tous les ans comme ça voire des travaux
j'arrive pas à comprendre comment c'est
possible c'est c'est très étonnant donc
à la férarock et maintenant faut y aller
avec les blancs allaient h4 g5 de toute
façon tu as pas le choix ça prend à tour
la case m6 et puis tu tentes des bagues
ou bien elle fait g5 direct ouais c'est
bien aussi c'est bien joué aussi
après ça laisse comprendre quatre dames
3 4 ou qu'étrangers 5
bon allez faut reprendre angers 5-1 vous
faire h4 peut-être g h et tour g1 est ok
ça n'a pas fonctionné mais là le
problème c'est qu'il a [ __ ] en dames
francs à froid f3 ya tour g1 contre
attaque sur sur g7
ok on va peut-être f6 enfin deux
variantes contre attaque la dame et
protège le pion belle s'est perdu
ouais c'est bien vu de la part de willy
fans et là c'est fini
23 coup franc d un dame 36 d'un f77
change tout et c'est gagné
où il fan qui va égaliser alors je sais
pas si vous entendez fort les travaux à
proche de chez moi
si vous entendez fort je vais fermer la
fenêtre m
je sais pas quel point ça s'entend un
peu ça continue encore trois quatre
minutes je vais m'arrêter je vais fermer
la fenêtre mais la femme c'est que ce
point là il ya du vent pour une fois il
fait monsieur crème moins de shoots
d'habitude quoi on n'entend pas ouais ok
si c'est vraiment très faible c'est moi
qu'il entend former je préfère profiter
d'un peu de vent parce qu'ils paient
hyper chaud
non mais là en fait il en fait un
immeuble proche de chez moi il rajoute
un étage il rajoute un étage en fait
bêtement et ça fait des mois le retour
de la ronde en a donc fait hacher oui en
fait je crois que tu as un sais pas si
c'est passé chez les bouddhistes ou je
sais pas quoi août à un enfer comme ça
ou c'est un éternel recommencement de la
même chose et genre c'est censé être un
truc infernale ai je dit quelque part
que ce speech sc une simulation de ce
truc là j'utilise ça ce matin c'est un
genre de simulation infernal du même
truc qui recommence toujours et en fait
c'est terrible c'est terrible le format
est terrible c'est terrible le mythe de
sisyphe à celle existant mythologie mais
c'est sûr que c'est un truc classique
infernale je suis sûr que c'est c'est un
cc c'est un sujet d'enfer
thématique pourquoi au premier tour ce
qui leur promet tour toutes les semaines
en fait
tf ça recommence toutes les semaines
c'est la même chose un c mais oui je
suis sûr qu'il ya forcément
ok elle voudrait essayer de faire un
cavalier aussi ça à faire d'alger 3 ici
sur dame français s'inquiètent d'un
projet sept matches et essayer qu'avait
lieu 4 après vous allez voir dans ce
terrible mais j'imagine tours fc est ici
white on essaie de ces logiques sur
cavaliers ou six au moins y a pas de
problème puisque tu es bien défendu elle
va faire cavalier 4 avec je faisais que
l'afrique ait eu quatre sur dan des
quatre tentes un quart et les problèmes
6 échecs mois elle va faire un bep 3 à 9
h 4 alors l'attention de 4 avec avec
cavaliers avec deux amis cavalière
faisait ya d'armes problème de rats
tient ses jolies d'un problème de et
tour d un don qu'elle fait caillasser 1
elle défend quand même avec les blancs
tour des 1re et on reprend tout reprend
h si ces dames j'ai un aide à mesure ça
fait mal adam jones a fait très mal à
ces terribles under way ça attaque là ça
défend la même être un échec est la plus
d'échecs et c'est dur là pour mouiller
double à l'église égalisation de yi fan
un partout toi donc là j'attends avec
impatience les olympiades avis ça dure
un mois et demi ça c'est encore autre
chose
ça dure un mois et demi c'est encore un
autre délire aïe aïe aïe donc on a de
nouveau une hache dof
c'est un match à thème un ses nageurs
sur majorque
et pourtant les noirs les noirs
l'emportent faut de fouet trois mois
joue le petit truc insipide mais qui
peut donner un avantage
merci annie cnic hommage un bon elle va
peut-être faire un petit à 5 c'est 30 de
l'espace allèles dame jouée la casse des
5 sur la même histoire avec ce trou et
ça joue tout sur la casse des 5 voir
comment ça évolue autour des 1
d'accord ça se met sur la colonne carré
lycéens qui rallie à 2 qui a et b 4 qui
est des cinq peut être une idée c'est un
plan thématique qui peut exister je sais
pas à quel point il est réalisable mais
c'est juste pour montrer des idées quoi
ce transfert de kara l'hiver dessins
qu'il est joli
il peut aussi arriver comme ça
luc la case et 5 importante en fait ce
cavalier qui sert vraiment à rien c'est
notre mauvaise pièce si on pouvait le
téléporté en dessin qu'on serait beau
avec les blancs ça je sais pas si vous
le comprenez dans le tchat ce truc là
est-ce qu'on est assez intelligent dans
le chat pour le voir ça ou pas ou est ce
qu on a été trop intelligent expliquant
c'est un peu la question qu'on se pose
en 3 h 2
donc voilà on veut ramener ce cavalier
ici du coup c'est long et c'est pas
obligatoire qu'on arrive à faire l'un
des deux plans parce que ça prend quatre
coups quand même mais à terme si on y
arrive on serait on serait très bien un
autre truc qu'on aimerait bien faire
parfois c'est fou j'ai 5 fu pro f 6 pour
gagner la casse des cinq mais là encore
c'est difficile à réaliser ce terrible
avec haïti les anges et 6
pour les noirs qui se mobilisent un peu
à la halle dame g31 ça couvre bien
regarder al bonbons cover la côte et
blanc le roi qui protège le pion le fou
qui peut revenir en g2 c'est solide et
parfois après des f4 qui peuvent partir
on va voir ce que ça donne j'ai regardé
moi j'ai pas j'ai pas l'oeil sur les
autres matches joués john qui mène koné
roux qui mène katia qui est en train de
massacrer bibi sahara pas étonnant et
donc on est finalement sur le match le
plus serré 1 1 on a on a le nez creux un
pur pour le choix des matches on n'est
pas mauvais les amis on n'est pas
mauvais en choix de matches on prend les
bons matches et ça danse à rennes jouera
dans un deuxième temps je vous montre
les autres matches sur ad ici corrie qui
jouera contre ana ou chez nina kosteniuk
guérilla que c'est une queue beau match
en perspective sarah ça qui jouera
contre elena c'est le match qu'on
regardera elle avait joué ensemble dans
déjà la d1 fois irina crush coup à jouer
contre quelqu'un d'autre croche je me
rappelle plus et arica contre tatev
abraham yann mais je on suivra on suivra
ça alors dessin qui scipion prend
cavaliers prend et elle a oublié d'un
machin à c'est la tuile quand même assez
là tu l'as pour mon jeu assez une pièce
en un coup c'est pas de chance elle
s'est mise dans un clouage et si elle
trouve d'un machin avec les blancs c'est
game les amis à et c'est terrible à ses
tarifs de 2 une question de coût elle a
oublié d'un machin terrible terrible
elles sévissent dans un clouage de vous
jamais mais ne vous mettez jamais dans
des clouage les amis c'est jamais
terrible
en tout cas fait très attention la pièce
est cloué plus personne ne peut venir la
défendre
le cavalier g6 ne peut pas venir et
qu'il allait prendre des 5 arrive au
prochain quoi qu'il se passe
du rhin
ouais le mythe de sisyphe je connais du
coup avec le rocher que tu dois monter
qu'ils redescendraient c'est un peu ça
en fait ce tournoi c'est un mythe de
sisyphe en fait exactement cela il a top
merci pour pour le petit point culture
mythologie mais c'est un peu ouais voilà
c'est un peu le ce sera un peu l'âme et
la métaphore de ce tournoi a quelque
part je sais pas si vous êtes d'accord
avec ça d'un mach 1 tour 17
et il va ya voir qu'il est prend des 5
c'est une pièce tout bêtement c'est
juste une pièce pour pourri fans
après peut-être que mou je ne veux pas
abandonner pour pas avoir une partie de
plus ça joue en 5 rue saint henri fans
qui calcule mais je sais pas quoi
puisque acquis et prend des 5 c'est
vraiment une pièce un bon moi aussi je
veux faire fou prend des cinq francs des
cinq tours prend des 5 c'est aussi une
pièce en fait tout est une pièce ici
peut-être moi je la ferai même comme ça
vous prend vous prend tout reprend pour
se simplifier la vie
face à ces simples aux siens oui puisque
à la fin sur dame français de il y
aurait des tours c'est un tour france et
donc tu peux faire tout reprendre tout
reprend fou prend et tu crains pas dames
1er tour 6 1 où il vous prend et là tu
crains pas de me prend les atours c1
donc tu donnes même par un pion c'est
vraiment une pièce net de plus voilà
soit tu es fou les 600 premiers soit tu
es fou prend 17 à [ __ ] on baissa de la
dame prend besset est désolé mais oui
feu caf invoquée c'est juste une pièce
net sans aucune compensation de plus
donc il n'y a rien à regarder c'est
vraiment abandon normalement c'est
vraiment abandon
ouais et d'ailleurs à la bande heures et
ce qui est encore une partie à suivre
dur à dire si ça commence en retard oui
de justesse
on va le voir et du coup ça va faire
prendre du retard
là elles ont dû finir au gong
voir ce que ça donne le a6 avant c'est
une variante jouable pour les noirs mais
ça donne un bon et audemars roxio blanc
généralement on va voir ce que ça se
fait c'est quoi surtout reprend des cinq
héros tout reprend des cinq à licha en
fait il y avait une dame en h1 qui
protégeait
lara 3
ahdab a vu la dame en agenda courait
pour marron que willy fans change
puisque c'était plutôt bien passé sa
nature fait avec les noirs mais elle a
quand même décidé de changer voilà pris
à la quand même pris un ascendant déjà 2
1 si elle gagne salle a3 ça va commencer
à c'est je pense une partie hyper
important pour le jour où elle a
vraiment besoin de revenir au elle a
vraiment besoin de revenir au score
elle a un énorme besoin de revenir au
score mais est une tour en d1
peut-être fou f1 qu'avait lieu de elle
va peut-être se replacer ou cavaliers
c'est de le fou en f4 et s'est tapé sur
ce pion des six si elle le peut ça peut
être une idée pour les blancs les noirs
vont vouloir jouer baies 5 pouces ou des
5 donc j'ai là nous vient de mon gollier
elle joue pas mal hein mon jeu vous la
pressez pas
terrible c'est terrible la position à
jouer avec les blancs tu as l'impression
d'être bien mais parfois ça peut ça peut
bien se retourner voir comment elle s'en
sort dans les autres matches est ce
qu'il ya eu une évolution au tableau
d'affichage dans les autres partis sont
pas non plus terminé
ah je vois une zone qui vient de de
faire l'écart ouais mais green eyes
c'est vrai qu'elle n'a pas gagné un seul
match c'est elle qui avait perdu le 11 0
ou nice semble pas être la joueuse la
plus la plus dangereuse bon pour elle ce
sera le dernier tournoi ainsi elle perd
elle aura joué 3 3 speech s et trois
défaites au premier tour donc vous nay
et menés au score à la marque de deux
points katia qui à mon avis on va aller
jeter un oeil va faire enfler le score
face à face à bibi ça ou pas tu as un
peu sur la fin de cette finale
c'est intéressant de voir si le pion des
réussi à verte la marche avant le roi
peut venir en d2 pour essayer de le de
s'interposer mais la bbc à peu revenir à
la marque un retour 8 et un coût et que
les blancs tillon fier un pion et demi
de moins mais qui vont récupérer ont
récupéré deux as et ça va aller en fait
ouais là elle s'en sort
katia avec les blancs et le roi bien
placé elle fait g4 pour éviter les
rebonds food et 1 c'est bien joué ça
attaque le pion est ça l avait pas vu g4
pareil c'est logique mais fou d un bien
joué parce que si elle fait fou prend f3
phuc ranger 4 les trois pions seront
très forts qui a été 3 il faut faut
prendre trois cavaliers f2
ou cavaliers au sein qu'il faut à tout
prix encore mieux cavale f5 sa 15e 500
attaques et j'ai catway et l'a peut-être
qu'à et c7 est pas idiot pour aller
gagner un tempo sur le fou dont elle
fait qu'il y ait des 3 kgs ses sept
quarts les b5 b6 à manager 4 après c'est
dur avec moi si peu de temps sur la
pendule a été obligé de près move sans
arrêt le roi qui va venir e4 en d5
elle veut essayer de faire bessette fou
prend cavaliers prend à y recourir en
défense cavaliers qui vient défendre
alors là tu peux pas échanger et je
pense que bibi sarah va revenir là quand
même trois pions pas scellier qui avance
et les blancs réussit pas du tout à
orchidées 8 c'était bizarre
oh là là c'est terrible ce qu'elle a
fait et heureusement
heureusement pour pour bibi sarah ça va
pas suffire
elle revient un peu dans le match ok
bien joué de la part de blizzard on va
retourner sur même jour qui a qui
restent qui restent dans le match quoi
c'est important et un petit coup nehru
on va voir
[Musique]
pis en pis elle qui va faire l'écart à
la contrebasse schalit vie qui fait
l'écart d'accords un pipi qui se place
lui qui fait l'effort et donc il va nous
rester cette partie en fil rouge avec
willy fans qui a comme un pion plus ok
y'a le pion à f4 en l'air il ya b6 qui
peut être attaqué via des tours c'est 6
mai la b2 qui peut sauter aussi il ya eu
4 aussi en l'air
tout cas bien joué et salua alex la
courbe et src mois et guillaume dans le
chatt salut les gars et c'est pas une
redif skyblues proche une redif en face
c'est juste le même tournoi qui
recommencent à chaque fois mais c'est
pas une rediff ou alors tu faisais une
blague par rapport aux faits du
recommencement éternelle et et de ceux
dont on parlait tout à l'heure
et donc ça recommencera aussi la semaine
prochaine voilà pour ceux qui pour ceux
qui voulaient qui voudrait on est
certain ce tronc recommencera une
dernière fois mercredi prochain
un dernier au départ j'ai envie de dire
c'est 1,3 d'entraînement non saint-trond
officielle à cannes 50 mille balles en
jeu en tout il ya une idée avec tours d2
après je crois qu'il ya plus trop
d'idées stade cheikh honnêtement
pour les blancs tu as juste un gros
pions de moins en fait y'a pas vraiment
d'idée à voir ce que même tour des trois
tués je vais rien attaqué en fait le fou
et 5 est trop fort donc jules qui va
juste prendre le tarot monde jaune qui
va bonnement et simplement prendre le
tarot elle avait gagné la première
partie et elle n'a pas su pas su tenter
sa chance dans la deuxième avec les
blancs face à une joueuse comme bouillie
phan fah l'essai de capitaliser un
rapidement mais là j'ai l'impression que
maintenant c'est une grosse domination
de la joueuse chinoise en continu c'est
bien bravo à elle est ce que je suis
rien avec le maître hier soir aurait
complètement très belle aux matières
très belle omelette
mais là en fait c'est et puis en plus
faye a rien à dire c'est juste visuel
après faut réussir à monter les pièces
peut-être envoyer le pion b passez vous
est sûrement ça en fait sûrement ça le
plan principal mais en vo n'y a rien à
dire juste la position et délabré pour
les blancs et auquel et noir peuvent se
tromper où il peut y avoir du contre
j'ai un moment donné qui arrive ou quoi
ça c'est possible mais ça doit pas être
le cas
jean la dame c3 pour défendre le
cavalier mettre échec elle avait
clairement pas vu
c'est cette affaire tout recettes je
pense
ouais
le cavalier attaqué le pion des cas tu
vas tomber et maintenant je prends des
deux arrêts c'est fini direct on reprend
des huit france et cette souffrance et 3
pardon et sur dame prend des deux il ya
d'armes français 8 mai c'était sûr que
ça allait craquer un jour ou l'autre
pour les blancs à mon jules qui se
trouve encore des ressources à mesdames
17 bêtement bape rendu toujours dame
france et 8
mesdames 17 juste bêtement elle fait
tout reprendre quatre points à ses tours
en 1 mata c'est joli ça elle en veut
plus encore willy fans bon du coup le
match le plus serré c'est le match qu'on
va aller voir le match de katia contre
bibi sahara en deuxième mi temps
fava est quand même temps à cannes je
crois qu'il reste un mois et demi en
tout mais il est pas chez moi il n'est
pas chez moi il reste un mois et demi en
tout alors je mettre une petite pub et
moi je vais faire une petite pause alors
on va faire comme les jouets je vais
faire une pause de cinq minutes
elle vous le tournoi ça le web elle
jouera après je vous met une partie en
fond qu'est ce que je peux vous mettre
comme parties doivent une partie j'ai
joué hier et je reviens bien toujours
vient très vite fait de servir un verre
d'eau
bon les gars on va regarder c'était
reparti j'ai oublié de remettre le micro
mais aussi puisqu'à les travaux qui sont
repartis mais je sens que ça va pas
durer longtemps mais je vais vraiment
laissé la teinte rouverte sinon je vais
j'ai juste mourir de chaud en fait ça va
être terrible a du coup est-ce que ça
rejoue pas ça rajoute toujours pas fort
et moins de pose à moi je vais te le
faire le nouveau sens à défiler ce pitch
est ce qu a voir ça ça va ça va être
bâclé ans ça va être bâclée en dix
minutes
ça n'a pas duré bien longtemps les
parties elles vont s'enchaîner pour
mettre enzo pour meubler
voilà en fait taxées quatre c4 4
semaines de meublage ludwig parce que
c'est le même tournoi tu as rien rater
là depuis les quelques jours où tu étais
pas trop là sur les speech est à rien
rater je te rassure t était toujours tu
es toujours à jour quoi tu es toujours à
jour c'est toujours la même chose
bon ben on va un peu aller regarder bibi
sarah du coup on va un peu aller
regarder bibi sahara on va voir ce que
ça donne c'est vraiment pénible je sais
pas ce qu'ils font là ils font vraiment
juste à côté de chez moi je la ressens
kick ass de la ferraille je sais pas ce
qu'ils font j'espère que ce sera pas le
même format pour les speech est ce mix
d'ailleurs j'espère qu'ils vont pas
faire la même chose pour les speech est
mixte et ouais fable sera cannes pendant
deux mois avec comme jd zig et il
commentera vendredi et dimanche
donc les speech est donc n'hésitez pas à
venir voir un psy cola dimanche dernier
il y avait il y avait quasiment personne
pour la finale il y avait très peu de
monde donc n'hésitez pas à aller voir
aller voir à venir vendredi et dimanche
pour pourvoir fab ce que vous dites
toujours pourquoi les papables quoi y'a
papa mais comment et quand y'a pas bien
personnes mobilisées vous en venez
présenter vous et venez venez dimanche
et il sera là ce soir aussi pour la
master class mais mais venez dimanche du
coup il tendu avec andrea exactement et
ce sera la même chose vendredi et
dimanche du coup ce qui me permet à moi
de me reposer un petit peu je vous avoue
quatre semaines d'affilée j'aurais pas
tenus en fait j'aurais fait un burn-out
je pense que j'aurais fait le béarn out
si si j'avais fait le speech est tous
les jours pendant pendant pendant un
mois je pense à un moment juste eu tu
tues tu craques quoi
est-ce quelque chose de prévu jeudi sur
la chaîne
why aura normalement une ce battle avec
alexandra botez mais bon j'attends quand
même jeudi pour confirmer parce que ça
elle nous en a annulé trois le matin du
truc
pourquoi pas une 4e et l'annulation
verra on verra normalement mais
normalement oui mais les bat normalement
vont partir ouais j'avais 300 kg je sais
pas du coup j'aime j'aime bien annoncer
des trucs à l'avance mais quand tu t'en
es déjà fait annuler trois dernières
minutes on a les sanctions définies
alors ce sera soit un jour de ban soit 3
jours de ban soit band fg pas encore
décidé de la sanction pour les défaites
mais ça peut aller jusqu'aux band aid je
pense je pense que suivant le contenu de
la partie ça pourrait aller jusqu'à des
banh def
on verra mais un jour de ban ce serait
quand même un minimum
je pense et le time control ce sera 3 +
0 band fc chooz ouais mais ce serait
mérité quoi ce serait mérité donc on
verra on verra on verra suivant le
contenu on en discutera avant le match
mais c'est sûr que des 24 heures de ban
tomberont en cas de défaite ça c'est sûr
trois jours c'est très probable aussi
band f
s'il ya vraiment voilà on verra on verra
on verra donc bibi ça avec les blancs
ban pourquoi pour des fêtes quand le
sabbat talent fait et lewin ils auront
quoi rien ils ont eu droit de jouer de
participer peut-être là au prochain ce
battle s'ils en ont envie
là plus personne pour se présenter ben
voilà au moins il y aura au moins on
arrêtera de dire je veux jouer le sabbat
thales que comme on fait pour s'inscrire
comment on joue ça permettra aux gens de
prendre un peu leur responsabilité un
je suis là je dis sabana un jour tu vas
un seul ban trois jours tu lâches pas de
saab
ban def tarif 10 e
on a tout à perdre rien à gagner à bah
ouais mais bon moi j'ai déjà envoyé 550
euros quand même un dans les battles je
dis ça je dis rien tu vois donc au bout
d'un moment il faut que faut que tout le
monde est à perdre moi j'ai perdu 550
euros
vous allez être band fc équitable moi je
préfère être ban tef que de que perdre
150 balles un allez on sait salam sall
est pour le moment donc voilà ça
permettra à tout à chacun de prendre sa
responsabilité
chacun prend ses responsabilités nous on
en voit combien dans la jafza bataille
du contenu pour un seul battles et
passent pas censé coûter de l'argent il
y aura débat d'edf
d'après vous avez le droit de pas jouer
un sale tour n'est pas j'oblige personne
a joué un jeu oblige personne à jouer tu
veux pas jouer tu joues pas tu veux pas
risquer le bad days tu joues pas c'est
pas grave
ça m'a un an je vois la baisse gars pour
le vent les gens y viennent y perd 2 il
se passe rien ils sont pas entraînés
bombes à eau - au moins au moins ça va
jouer un peu pour quelque chose
des gens sont pleutre dès que ça
commence à pas mettre un peu d'enjeu ça
ça a commencé à challes et ils vont
jouer plus motivés mais voilà la levée à
lever k qui comprend le délire ah non
mais c'est comme dans tout non mais pour
prendre le ban des faut vraiment faire
quelque chose de grave qu on vraiment
perdre un truc imperdable ou pas le
bundle sera difficile à faire quoi faut
vraiment faire une très mauvaise partie
pour le band of faut rater à une
multitude de maths en 1 consécutifs ou
quoi le ban trois jours ouais une dame
en a je pense à être ban trois jours et
le ban un jour ce sera une bonne défaite
quoi on va voir nan ban des faut
vraiment faut vraiment y aller 1
un congrès c'est une grosse perf un gars
bien mieux classés cas l'enjeu bas il
gagne c'est tout quoi calenge bas il
gagne ça peut lui donner le droit de
rejouer ou bon bah voilà il est heureux
quoi fin il a gagné
ah oui par contre s'il ya quelqu'un qui
allume scop fish classé ban des photos
matic ouais ça par contre si un gars
dont je suis sûr que qu'il a triché ça
ce sera un band est automatique et
well as la cbf sans réfléchir ouais si
un module sebban des automatiques sans
même réfléchir une seule seconde mais
sans appel des fêtes avec honneur contre
l'adversaire paraissant lots surestimé
sa fait ban
ouais ça fait bad un jour un jour 24
heures 24 heures généralement les vannes
seront entre 24 et 72 heures il y aura
pas il y aura pas plus n'y aura pas plus
y'aura pas plus ça va suer demain puis à
plein de gens qui vont gueuler pourquoi
il ya débat n'est tout ça est
insupportable de toute façon si les gens
sont insupportables par rapport à ça il
y aura plus de ce battle et ce sera un
point final et là il va y avoir foi h3
ou là le cavalier ou deux qui va suez
annonce a su déjà les gens dès que tu
rajoute un peu d'enjeu sassus ça chiale
ses terres il en fait les rois je viens
encore bon ça à faire matin fou et 5
contres échec ça paraît sympa mais faut
pas se retrouver dans un clouage qui
sert à rien ou la sacema ou ce clip elle
voulait faire autour des 4 bon ça aurait
perdu quand même un jour assure non non
c'est déjà en train de chialer dans le
chatt sa chan déjà maintenant tu parles
de ban social déjà assez impressionnant
c'est impressionnant certains sont
d'ailleurs aux échecs que toi à
trackmania
c'est déjà ça oui justement je suis pas
de cette battle à trackmania quoi
tu peux expliquer les règles pour ceux
qui connaissent pas ben là en fait à des
partis qui jouent en cadence trois plus
un puisque c'est celle qui marque le
plus de points après 70 minutes de jeu
gagnant gagne le match en fait bêtement
mais en plus ça va être intéressant
l'histoire des bagnes aura peut-être
beaucoup moins de joueurs candidat pour
jouer ça ce sera cool s'écoula après
il ya du bullet après oui mais je voulu
expliquer simplement le match sans trop
parler de cadence passera beaucoup plus
drôle
ce sera beaucoup plus drôle
farroqui sera marrant voilà les matchs
sont pas passionnant +1 les scores sont
assez ya même pas un seul match serré la
lega ya que des massacres
on est vraiment mal tombée on est
vraiment mal tomber il n'y a rien à
regarder
c'est le match le plus serré et c'est un
massacre mais bon ok c'est bibi sarah
gagne ça là il peut y avoir un match
sinon ça va être dur se perd avec
honneur sur une grotte savannah oui bah
oui non mais en fait c'est il n'y a pas
deux il n'y a pas de défaite qu'ils
aillent en fait c'est ça qu'il faut que
vous compreniez en fait la seule chose
qui peut sauver des banh un seul c'est
qu'on gagne le match en fait la seule la
seule chose qui peut qui peut sauver le
ban d'un saab ayant perdu c'est que
l'équipe gagne en fait voilà c'est bien
joué ça fou prend f7 et b4 maintenant
qu'ils aient eu ces six pour enfermer le
cavalier bien joué de la part de katia
c'est la seule chose qui peut sauver en
fait c'est faut compter sur l'équipe en
fait une fois que la partie est perdue
la seule chose qui peut sauver le le
seul c'est l'équipe
c'est ça le truc en fait c'est qu'après
le sahb aura quand même cette porte de
sortie en cas de défaite
donc il faudra soutenir l'équipe pourra
soutenir les autres quoi ce sera ça en
fait le fait votre porte de sortie
c'est ça le truc en fait si l'équipe
gagne évidemment il y aura pas de duras
pas de ban en fait si l'équipe gagne on
gagne ensemble si l'équipe air ben
forcément ban y aura c'est normal après
un jeu je vois pas pourquoi ce je vois
pas ce qu'il ya dedans normal en fait je
ne comprends pas en fait
ah ça change tout à ben ça change tout
oui et non oui et non si tu gagnes si
l'équipe gagne apaya pas être ban c'est
logique ça c'est logique ça a été quand
même sauvé des eaux quoi t'es quand même
sauvé des eaux
ah ouais c'est tu peux être sauvée des
eaux quoi c'est l'esprit c'est logique
mais je vois pas ce qui a dit logica
panne les gens qui ont perdu en fait en
cas de défaite du match je vois je vois
pas ce que fab de base' misons mais dix
minutes de ban pour ceux qui ont perdu
franchement c'est pas assez 1
franchement c'est pas assez un ouais
j'ai remis le tee shirt rose aujourd'hui
apporter bonheur hier bref habille les
gentils veut mettre que dix minutes de
ban
ça me paraît vraiment pas suffisant
ça me paraît pas suffisant pour moi pour
moi c'est pas suffisant mais de façon ça
me détendre à en plus après le match
mettre les balles me détendre à serques
ont quatre défaites en fait pour moi ce
serait une thérapie en plus je vais
noter les pseudos des gens qui perdent
pendant le match et tout ça ça me
détendre à je me sentirais bien et toute
façon s'il ya des gens qui essayent de
se barrer du chat dans l'idée de se dire
je me barre du tchat et au moins
et au moins je me fais pas vannes cette
façon le nom sera noté la prochaine fois
je vous rejoins de ces messages il sera
bannie il sera à vannes encore plus saxe
il avait pris un jour il prendra trois
jours pour fuites et les excuses de j'ai
dû partir jouer pas suivre le match
jusqu'au bout il sut pas son équipe
jusqu'au bout donc du coup sebban aussi
il y aura beaucoup de possibilités de
ban
ouais et quelque part perdre me fera
plaisir ouais donc ouais dans les
déserteurs se font défoncer bon alors
fou b6 est ce qu'il va y avoir cavaliers
prend elle à fait fou des deux îles l
attaque par l a pas vu le plus réussi je
crois à yap cavale et c3 encore ok c'est
une bonne nouvelle pour bibi ça on va
voir si elle la tient
ma théorie avec toi il ya toujours un
pion de moi on va avoir quelques points
6 food et deux à al kamali peut être
enfermé intéressant et maintenant j'ai 4
h 4 h 5 peut-être fouassin quoi aussi
pas mal mais surtout à 7 du coup
maintenant le curé bloqués
non mais je préfère euros dont je
préfère payer des savais que les gens
soient ban honnêtement franchement je
préfère je préfère je préfère ban des
gens que que faire payer les sacs d'ifd
je trouve ça plus intéressant en fait ça
ça me détendre quelque part je sais
pourquoi je paye au final je sais
pourquoi je paye en plus je sais
pourquoi je paye au moins
du coup fou prend à l'aca va gagner ce
final qui va gagner
donc
non mais façon dans l'est dans l'est
dans l'est dans les compétitions
sportives à force de perdre au bout d'un
moment on sanctionne les joueurs de
toute façon c'est normal c'est normal ça
se passe comme ça dans tous les sports
en fait un fer à force de perdre c'est
plus l'entraîneur qui prendrai après ces
fables qui peut prendre aussi c'est vrai
ça pour être les intervenants qu'ils
prennent
mais bon après le problème c'est que ces
chiens on aurait plus de master
classement avait plus rien meiway face
avec fabre pour être sanctionné
katia paix poujois web et les matchs
sont faciles la vraie vraiment vraiment
il ya des gros écarts partout il n'y a
pas deux il n'y a pas de suspense appris
à jouer john qui peut perdre sur
connexion mais c'est pas très
intéressant mais les autres matches
c'est c'est un massacre total à thiaroye
match 6 bien protégé par le pion à f4
donc nous mettra tous rangs des huit
sûrement elle peut pas vraiment faire de
f3 proment et adam d2
non mais c'est vrai que ça donne en un
petit intérêt demain ce sera ce sera un
peu le truc intéressant
ce sera le truc intéressant demain
du coup je sais pas si je suis j'espère
qu'on gagne ou qu'on perde ce compliqué
tout ça
les deux ministres ont peut-être plus
relevée ou pas hein
ça peut aussi dépendre du score en fait
peut-être si on perd c'est ray ce sera
24 heures de ban
et si on se fait écraser jeu sera 72
heures on verra alors que je réfléchisse
exactement au barème
bon après si on n'a pas de joueurs on
perdra par forfait un problème kamel
daniel sait que si on adapte aux
qualités de la partie vu la qualité des
parties habituelles je pense que ça va
être band f pour tout le monde très vite
en fait je pense que non la qualité des
parties est d'être aux misérables pour
pour imaginer adapté à la qualité des
parties face à red band aid pour tout le
monde tout le temps en fait donc même
pour les gagnants d'ailleurs
malheureusement donc je pense que ça
peut pas être le barème
la qualité par rapport au niveau wallon
ouais après c'est a pas assez d'abonnés
ben voilà on arrêtera les battles et
puisse pas grave mais au moins ça donne
du piment sinon straw toujours la même
chose non mais si tu fais balanda banda
débat ne doit pas toutes les parties à
julio red shirt faut être sérieux faut
voir la qualité des parties en fait si
dès qu'il ya un truc grave tu mets banda
en fait il y aura band est vraiment à
toutes les parties les rois qui restent
au centre ceux qui connaissent pas la
théorie ceux qui savent pas jouer les
finales enfin il ya trop de ya trop
d'erreurs gravissime à chaque partie ça
peut pas aller en fait les maths en un
raté fayat il n'y a pas ça pourra pas
aller comme ça
non non dames en 1 sait rien en fait 1
dames en 1 pour l'esa battles et ses
sites en donne qu'une dans la partie des
jabots quoi il va peut-être un retour à
8 tours prend et on prend à deux mais
c'est pas si clair la position
si ludovic pearl away si ludique jouer
qui perd à wayaux rabanne quand même
hein ça change rien ça change rien il
n'y a pas de passe droit c'est quoi la
dame en un coup tu t'es vous serez la
dame en adresse et sa super tadam ans
d'un coup enfin ça mettra du piment ce
sera cool on réagit ce sera la bonne
la bonne open à l'apa à katia qui a pas
réussi grand chose après les biens
autant nous calvo de façon elle a gagné
le match tranquillement
il va pas y avoir de problème joué john
qui a toujours ses problèmes de
connexion apparemment non là ça va mieux
je crois voilà il ya dame croyait froid
maintenant voilà on va faire on fait le
score il n'y a pas de tout repos f2 ici
même dame coin f2 dame 31
c'est déjà une option je pense 1 il ya
toujours eu deux aussi voyez une
ribambelle à tourcoing n2 c'est le plus
simple
il va falloir échanger les dames après
laffaire d'alger quatre d'entre eux
quatre ces finiens c'est complètement
fini roigé 7 5
il ya même pas d'un bébé cet échec je
passion encore une partie derrière
on va aller ses quartiers à gagner ça
très tranquillement
bon
la dame f3 et f4 ici échanges et l'aida
voilà c'est bien jouer kaka qui le voit
vite et c'est gagné et ça fait 5 1
bon honnêtement je sais pas trop quoi je
sais pas quoi suisse que tous les matchs
sont quasiment mathématiquement terminée
sa fille lou and june mais ouais bon
peut-être on va aller voir jouer john
tout le reste est quasiment
mathématiquement terminée
ça traîne pas aujourd'hui un alors joué
in june il ya une série d ouais ça si
derrière ses lacets la s
mais non ça 6,5 10 minutes s'arrête et
puis là aujourd'hui c'est plus long bon
de toute façon on ratacher vous ratez
rien à la vraiment ce qu'il ya déjà un
pion de plus pour les blancs à aimer
elle va être il va être récupérée après
l'échangeur 5 et prendre ces cinq way
doit vite apprendre en c3 ou prendre 5
en premier
elle ne pas récupérer le pion s'étonnant
sa dame des 4 et f4 ses pions de +1 à f4
à le faire f 6 km il ya des coups il ya
des coups comme ces 4 6 qui peuvent être
intéressants des emprunts f6 c4 c'est
logique
est-ce que je tire un peu ouais ouais ça
va streamé ce soir il y aura il y aura
la master class de fab
alors
du coup ça prend prend
je vais avoir sûrement s'éprend des cinq
ouais mais ça mais tour à b1 pour jouer
sur le pion bessette a mis à tourcoing 3
foued 3 tours 5 pour eux un peu commencé
parfois f3 mais du coup 17 pouces et si
ça va être égal
fu 17
deux tours 8,3 feu 1
ces six tours à des 1
autour des 4
bon le petit avantage c'est que pions en
dessin il va être fixée mais ça va rien
donner
histoire des trois on va faire g3
on va voir si elle peut l'apprécier
normalement ça donne rien mais peut-être
des 4 1 pour tout échange est allé
récupérer ces cinq c'est pas idiot
ouais c'est bien joué ça tout est changé
et ça va faire nul
il y aura deux points d'écart alors
encore une petite possibilité de revenir
mais ça c'est drôle c'est au tour de
tours de tours cation en 2 tours 4 pions
bref il faudra écrire la constitution du
banneret
du coup peut-être pour le premier match
aura commencé par les vannes de 24
heures histoire d'habituer les gens on
verra d'ailleurs l'objectif c'est quand
même de monte à 72 heures mais peut-être
pour le premier match faudra des pannes
de 24 heures simplement
foucque alpaga veut pas faire à tour à
six ailes faut faire gaffe parce que
quand tu prends tour a3t mal j'aurais
les revenus ray mais la super mal vu la
finale en fait fallait faire tomber
trois tours ces deux tours à troy bell
s'est mise mal la joue à une joue de
maintenant il ya tour j'ai quatre tours
h4 assez fou en fait de se retrouver mal
hein mais c'est parce que l'autre est
mal autant et elle avoue la force et
j'ai compris ses adversaires étaient mal
autant salah excité et elle s'est foutu
dans la merde tout seul assez incroyable
de perdre cette finale quand même ce
terrible c'est terrible on va peut-être
à sauver quand même félicien d'arriver
dans le live m'écoute bienvenue à toi
je suis parent à six et cinq avaient
fait rage 5
j'ai peur que ça perdre cette histoire
enfin peur peur n'est pas le mot un
ouais le truc c'est que ça va faire nul
ça va faire nul trois réussissent ici
pourra g7 ça va faire nul vraiment pas
assez de temps après je pense c'était la
dernière partie de cette cadence ou pas
n'est ce pas là d un parti de la cadence
si et joris qui se lèvent 6 6 6 je
regardais avec le temps ça me paraissait
être la seule solution
du coup ça va repartir en pause les gars
c'était là d un parti de la cadence
comme tout à l'heure je vais vous
laisser cinq minutes avec une variante
du répertoire facile avec fab et je
reviens dans une hutte a tout de suite
les gars
bon alors
ce que vous venez de voir c'était une
partie de vlad
las quand même complètement gagnant pour
les blancs enfin je sais pas je m'en
fous j'ai 8 francs g7 g6 g7 quand même
les gars dans le chat quand même c'est
une partie de vlad
prenant c'est une partie longue je les
passe en accéléré du coup mais c'est une
jolie partie
bon du coup le lait les scores ouais bon
ah oui les fans qui étaient encore en
train de jouer bon ben on regarde un peu
le match se joue à une joue l'un au
retour jean viard sans grande conviction
parce que ça de vrai le suspense est pas
forcément un jouet non vasseur va la
suivre jusqu'à mon avis il y aura pas de
surprise mais bon on va quand même
regardé deux points c'est quand même
beaucoup surtout quand il ya un écart de
niveau tél
c'est le seul match où il ya un tout
petit peu de suspense à mon avis les
autres matches me paraissent ne paraisse
plier les autres matches me paraissent
plier personnellement j'ai pas quel est
votre avis votre avis personnel mais ça
me paraît être game partout ailleurs
ça me parait de game j'ai du mal à vous
inventez une heure et pas vous voulez
vous faire du solitaire inc parce que du
storytelling pardon ce qui s'est
vraiment le vide intersidéral
c'est à dire un jour de stream at war
avec magnus a déjà été fait plein de
fois en berne banovic après les tournois
actuels sont pas forcément et toi qui
m'intéresse le plus à tétouan du magnus
tour à titre perso donc je vais pas
aller l'esprit mais parce que ça me
samba il peut pas en fait
à l'ombre de caf qui prend une publiée
très heureux
dans les matches qui sont pliés katyal
haguenau c'est fini mathématiquement un
petit koné ruf
c'est quasiment fini joué john ça joue
encore et willy fans c'est
mathématiquement fini nokia d' un match
en réalité oui encore un tout petit
espoir même si jouer ndoumba pas good
time hammam zada c'est dur quand même
rosetta stone way rosetta stone c'est
pas mal sinon tu peux trouver une copine
italienne un nombre de caves
ça peut ça peut ça peut accélérer ton
apprentissage un soin c'est une idée
pour toi les bullet ça durera dix
minutes
les bullet ça durera dix minutes
ce qu'on va jouer à d'autres jeunes ans
j'ai pas le temps félix je préfère
essayer de jouer bien un jeu quoi
si charge une italienne l'ombre de cap
soit la solution 1 les italiennes elles
sont là
et j'avais bien aimé tft ouais mais il
change il changea échanges toutes les
deux semaines
on attend le début des bulles est
impatiemment
mais rosetta stone je crois que c'est
pas mal nombre de caves aussi
salut pantera fatalis
bon du coup les matchs sont là vous avez
les scores à gauche
le fait de changer régulièrement je
trouve ça ajoute une dimension
supplémentaire niveau skill ça change
l'adaptation aux échecs par exemple
d'ouverture s'est autorisé depuis
longtemps non les échecs c'est juste
tellement plus complet profond que tft
que ça pas besoin de changer en fait ils
metalink tft en fait tout le monde joue
pareil après deux semaines parce que le
jeu est hyper superficiel c'est pas du
tout le même niveau de complexité de
profondeur quel match et on va là on
suit joue njuguna imam ahmad zia
maintenant mais bon on suit on suit de
loin tu vois on suit vite fait un et
salue lucio là quand où comment sait
déjà qu'en club le club apporte beaucoup
mais le gros de très respectueux des
lois le club apporte pas grand-chose en
vrai c'est surtout personnelle ça donne
une motivation pour travailler le club
mais en vrai se passe pas le club qui te
fais vraiment progresser en soit c'est
plus le fait d'y aller jouer contre des
gens et de ça donne envie de les battre
et travailler ça peut être des patchs
échec tout le temps que ça a été parfois
je croyais à 300 400 ans avec le petit
rock où cohabitent et des micro atx
s'ils ont joué 300 400 ha tft je pense
que
ça se passerait bien quoi
n'en jetez plus vers concept inventé
mais a longtemps sa toile xviie siècle
je pense et puis on pouvait pas mettre a
avancé de 2,4 vers vers 1200 vers 1100
1200 il faut avancer que d'une case
mais juste jouer beaucoup plus profond
donc il ya beaucoup de manières
différentes de jouer à l'essai en train
de repartir on nous faut qu'on parte sur
le bon match c'est voilà ok alors il
faudrait que que bouna il emporte ainsi
gouda hyper là tous les matches seront
terminés une petite berlinoise
elle va prendre le cadre probablement
tour un cavalier des six à elle joue pas
la finale avec avec les blancs joue pas
la finale de la berlinoise elle rentre
dans cette position qui adore d'un petit
fin les blancs prétendre pour un petit
avantage grâce aux pions des cinq qui
est bien avancé dans le camp adverse on
va voir
je suis pas tout à fait d'accord avec ce
que dit iron kurt hectic plus un jeu à
des règles 5 puis il est dur
plus il dure appuyé le dur bas les dames
par exemple ça dure moins que les échecs
quand même ya moins de gens qui jouent
aux dames que de gens qui jouent aux
échecs clairement pas forcément c'est
aussi l'équilibré du jeu les échecs
c'est très bien équilibrée comme je sais
moi les matchs les matches c'est de plus
en plus les pauses en tout cas ces mois
de plus au nom c'est à licha en fait
c'est vraiment la même durée c'est juste
qu'à force de voir la même chose pour la
soixante fois d'affilée en force en fait
c'est ça devient ennuyeux en au milieu
et donc sa part et l'ont fait au début
tu as un peu l'excitation du truc
nouveau puis tu regardes un peu puis
quand on fait la force ce soit la même
chose qui qui recommence comme comme
c'est pas très intéressant ça ça en
devient long quoi
bon et là ça me parait dur pour les
blancs puisque ça va pas regarder les
fous ne peut pas aller ça ok tu peux
prétendre de ne pas perdre avec les
blancs mais ça peut pas être bien mais
là le cil cavalier a atterri sur ces 4
il va faire mal je pense tête des cinq
cavaliers affichent 6 ou cavaliers
affichent 6 direct pour s'en prendre aux
pions des 5 g absent que tu le gagnes le
pion des cinq échanges tout en 8 es tu
reviens en rêve 6 es tu gagnes le pion
des 5 et la partie et le match avec
alors là tu prend 1,4 et tu fait
cavalier à bonta déjà ton pions plus en
a quatre il va falloir être un peu
précises pour joue
calvet tout échange est pas sûr qu à la
gagne elle défend pas mal
là pas mal défendu avec les blancs bon
pour le moment il ya un genre de murs et
maintenant il va falloir progresser
droit ici à trois pouces et 3 à de vrais
caisse à ses couleurs pour jouer à une
joue nadal gagne autant bêtement ouais
bah il se sera pas n'y aura pas eu grand
suspense un suspense n'aura pas duré
très longtemps
alors est ce que est ce que vaille
charlie revient un peu je pense le
dernier espoir et surveille schalit
sinon ces matches-là weichs ali sql
ok vas échalier à les blancs qui vaille
schalit peut garder un poil de suspense
dans ces matches mais il faut qu'elle
gagne cette finale nul propose nul
dommage pour vaishali en plus ça a duré
60 coups donc je crois qu'on peut dire
que mathématiquement là tous les matchs
sont terminés les amis pour cette
première phase 2 rue aucun suspense 1
pour ces premiers matches la logique
aurait été confirmé par tous et la
prochaine ce battle en leur tige et
c'est ce sera demain à 20h45 mais il
faut que tu sois prêt si tu souhaites
participé à pouvoir te faire ban pendant
au moins 24 heures on va dire 24 heures
pour les premiers bataille non enfin que
tu sois tu sois prêt à assumer un ban en
cas de défaite
donc là tous les matchs où on finit bon
les gars c'est parti qui joue pour du
beurre on va dire le prouve à faire ban
de un jour la première fois parce que
sinon ça va encore gueuler et à est
comme ça on pourra attaquer les bains et
de façon ban des fonds en cas de triche
ça par contre ça reste bien évidemment
c'est une triche avérée à 100% le ban
des partira et
les banh de trois jours on attaquera à
partir de la prochaine fois
donc
tours c'est ici se fout des 3 mai pour
l'inscription est vers 20h15 on
commencera bon là ça joue encore un peu
non c'est parti
à quai 17 cas ici sans que ses parents
est tombé qatar est bien joué il ya pas
tomber entourage un bien joué juhan jun
mais a joué juhan john
elle va gagner cette finale
tranquillement vous allez voir il va
faire h4 elle va remettre le cavalier en
fuite pour attaquer les pions après pas
sûr à 100% que ce soit gagnant ou la
food & 5 c'est très mauvais c'était
terrible ça laisse leur avenir en d4
fallait faire ou à c5 a été roi qui
règnera m6 les cavaliers ont eu cinq
cavaliers prend et h 5h 6h set et ça à
faire quatre points d'écart joue à une
joue une facile je sais pas si les
autres matchs ont déjà commencé on peut
déjà partir vers les autres matches
parce que c'est déjà parti ce que sarah
ont déjà en train de jouer ce que ça va
être plus intéressant fait de suivre
non non ça va pas commencer à les autres
matchs commencent vraiment en retard
aujourd'hui que ça va finir tard voilà
la faf hier à 18h c'est terrible
c'est terrible a ironisé me casser un
peu chiant way change tu en veux pas en
même temps
c'est la chanson d'hier on réalise
héroïque tempête jusqu'au bout de
l'ennui le tu auras du speech us way
c'était la chanson avait fait hier avec
emile et images tout tout tout tout tout
tout tout tout tout tout tout tout tout
tout tout tout tout tout c'est génial
quoi je sais pas si j'ai déjà vu un
touriste curieux de ma vie en fait c'est
extraordinaire c'est extraordinaire
c'est dur à des beaux matches après je
n'en sais rien mais d'habitude y
commence à 16 heures les autres matches
même si ce n'est pas fini mais là ils
ont dit non c'est tellement bien on va
bien attendre que les premiers matches
soit terminé je fais tout tout tout vous
voyez c'est ça en fait c'est
extraordinaire
welch n est pas content pas quelqu'un
qui part en moto est très énervé des
motos et comment ça se fait que tu aies
sarah irina elle se rend compte de deux
fois premier tour assez le hasard le
tueur tueur c'est pas de chance c'est le
même tournoi c'est les mêmes a
pareillement là pour la peine
c'est beau quoi enfin moi je suis très
heureux de ça en fait
ce chien s'appelle enzo tony stark et
j'étais très heureux de quoi aussi oui
j'étais très drogue soit la même finale
pour les deux premiers tournois j'ai
préservé la botola il est énervé ce chat
enzo est très énervé des motos il aime
pas du tout en fait ça m'intéresse pas
ça fait trop de bruit et du coup il va
voyages font la moto qui passe à fond
n'a pas aimé bon si on suit cette partie
mais qui le match est plié un donc je
remette les scores des premiers 16e du
coup mais comme vous le voyez je vois
une zone qui gagne 6,2 un petit koné
roussissent de katharina l'agglo 7,3 ou
lifan 10,3 donc il n'ya pas de n'y a pas
de suspense un sage ou pour du beurre
c'est céder comme des parties amicales
elle a joué jun qui en plus va faire
enfler le score non non on n ose pas mon
chien
je faisais bien le tout tout tout tout
tout tout tout tout tout tout tout deux
émis les images je suis très heureux et
c4 alors est ce que c'est la dernière
partie qui est le maître cécile est la
même une maîtresse ce chien c'est une
amie diana parce que ça joue encore ou
pas non hop c'est fini pour ses rondes
là je vous avais dit un que c'était que
y avait aucun match qui allait se
retourner tous les matchs puis sur un
gros écart c'était sur une fois que que
les bullet ont été lancés
c'était sûr que ça allait finir comme ça
ce que le chien sera encore là quand
boris ou qui arrivera en un an
maintenant les boris tout cas elle
serait choqué s'il avait encore l'autre
chien donc ce chien par vendredi et
boris ou cas je vais la chercher à
samedi donc on va on va attendre les
nouveaux matches là c'est fini 1 c ces
premiers 8e de finale on va filer vers
les suivants
on va voir on va voir
by cécile est évident c'est vraiment et
ça rend extraordinaire c'est ce pitch
est vraiment extraordinaire
c'est quelque chose hein
c'est quelque chose ce que ja le couffin
la laisse les jouets wave et ouais ouais
j'ai tout j'ai tout j'ai touché tous
déjà pour boris ou cas traminer commence
plus dans la foulée à un avant avant il
a un truc super avec ses speech à ce
prince était le meilleur truc qui
faisaient ils ont arrêté quoi c'est
incroyable
assez terrible c'est terrible avant ils
ans et les matchs pour les autres
n'étaient pas encore terminées pareil
maintenant ils attendent que tous les
matchs soit terminé pour lancer ice est
terrible c'est terrible lisais un truc
bien en fait c'est de commencer quoi
qu'il en soit le deuxième match à 16
heures ouais c'était génial
c'est génial comme idée là il on a le
truc bien qu'ils aient ils ont enlevé
nom du coup y'a pas de pub assez
terrible c'est thierry c'était réviser
ce truc bien quoi qu'ils en disent ils
en ont et on va plus faire
j'étais tellement heureux à chaque fois
tu es tu arrivé dans le match et déjà
dix minutes de jouées tu étais bien quoi
bon alors est-ce que ça va être serré
les six mois au moins suivre un beau
match on espère quand même on espère
sahara qui avait gagné assez facilement
la dernière fois et je pense que sur le
papier en plus c'est théoriquement le
match qui peut être le plus serré ce que
côté hugh guérilla je pense que
guerrière va prendre part aux houches et
nina corps ici à gauche et dîna joue
aussi bien que dans les deux premiers
semis chess elle devrait bien s'en
sortir et arica contrat et ricanant
allemand est beaucoup plus forte que tu
as tu y es fabre à mian à mon avis
ça devrait bien se passer savard faire
quatre matches à mon avis après on verra
après on verra sur ses positions un peu
de gambie dame a accepté ou les pions
des essais ont disparu ou les deux
joueuses ont une activité plus ou moins
équivalentes face à être sensiblement
égal
mais de quoi peut-être remettre les
caméras
on va peut-être mettre les caméras je
suis en train d'évaluer le truc
ouais ça va on va essayer de jeu les
pass g passe comme ça en direct on va
mettre ça en bas du cou donc on va
mettre irina en haut on va se faire ça
en direct tranquille où ça apprend de
seconde
hop comme ça irina elle est là et ça
va est là
hop on va changer les noms ça je vais
réussir à écrire son nom bien cette fois
ci c'est sarah ras des mâles charrier et
l'autre côté on à irin accroche
on n'est pas mal
par de dormir web elles ont toutes l'air
un peu au bout de leurs lifeway
ils sont tous un peu au bout de leurs
life on l'a mais là il ya vous prend 1,4
pas centré par contre ouais il ya
l'échiquier qui a qui décode un peu mais
les calmes gmi j'ai mis ce que les
joueuses ont mis un je pouvais je peux
pas faire mieux les gars pour pour les
calmes
grâce à ryan cleary n'accroche ouais je
remette au centre c'est pas faux elle a
pas vus fou prend 1,4 à ces cons quand
même fou prend 1,4 cet effort qui
entourent france et un ca et gagnez un
pion gratuit un chômage en rater les
pions gratuit
c'est difficile
c'est difficile à rater des pions en un
sens fou qu'elle fasse un bon début de
match
irina si elle veut avoir une chance de
de faire quelque chose il va y avoir
quoi là peut-être f4e 5
jimena va essayer de partir pour ça plus
est dans son style sarah d'attaqué c'est
le fc sahara qui est là
commencez par ho5 elle va faire f 4
c'est sûr
on va voir ce que ça donne elle a chanté
affaire d'âme eu quatre jeux pan
d'affaires d'1 me 4 elle prend des cinq
prix chocs à la fin d'un mercato ça
marchait pas
et peut-être pas f4 mef 3 pour bloquer
cette diagonale
sur dames 4 qui est français 3 je vais
faire damage cet échec tout à l'heure je
sais pas si ça marche et on va voir
tour d un mois elle se garde le pure
life qui peut bouger 1
fou c'est sain car qu'est ce qu'elle
veut maintenant dame gecas ge peut pas
vraiment il ya le pion et l'ipad 2
j'allais dire d'alger 4 pas possible de
quant à miss teen en prépa sûr qu'elle
le voit un pas pris le pion à tout à
l'heure
on passe suis là non plus
prénom si elle veut gagner le match
irina crunch saura prendre les pièces
qu'on lui donne en un an quand même
alors donc heureusement que c'est pas un
seul bateau parce que là il ya un ban
d'un jour qui serait partie 1
ses talents bien que se rencontrent une
troisième fois la semaine fut le premier
tour j'espère le torture en fait
j'espère de ouf
t'imagines pas quel point j'espère je
pense à affaire d'âme détroit et tout
est changé
l'andam ces deux elle veut mater manger
ici sans du coup peut-être dam des deux
pourrait changer je voulais changer les
dames
elle fait dam des trois maintenant
expérience était pas très marrant ça
parce que l'ondam g5 avec l'idée de
faire dame c1 est rentré ou dame ces
cinq dames géant pour ça que voulaient
forcer les changes des dames ce que
c'est le roi blanc qui est faible ici
même très faible
donc
m dos dames ces cinq races m'attendant
elle va forcer la main basse arrêt
devrait la perte celle là et ça a donné
vraiment le long jeu au match
c'est mieux pour le match que sarah
perdent la première mais c'est moins
bien pour cornet tôt
est-ce qu'elle va réussir à mettre une
peau de banane d'un mec 4 et adam g iii
et à fougères pour le moment elle défend
bien
sarah sans que ça s'empire petit à petit
sa position ciao tony tony stark
un fou des deux fous j'ai cinq fois m6
n'avait elle a essayé de faire un truc
comme ça elle va l'arnaqué c'est pas sûr
que ce soit bien quand même sacrifice à
il ya food et deux intermédiaires que
possible via dame f1 elle fait à mes
fins et dames ainsi parlait le truc
logique en fait ce que tu veux plus on
prend avec 3 au prochain est à juste une
pièce de plus même hein tu prends du roi
hérault h un retour est ok c'est pas sûr
que tu gagnes avec les blancs mais tu
passes d'un truc où tu étais mal c'est
pas sûr que c'était une bonne idée cet
échec
elle va faire fouilles devraient fouet
f3 fou j'ai de très bien jouer sahara
est le fou en g2 elle vient bien rire
sont rois peut-être fou des fous
bessette aussi qu'ils peuvent traîner
faut faire attention de pas laissées
dame j'ai un matt wells et bien joué ça
et elles gagnent autant assez terrible
quand même pour irene accroche elle en
rigole ça elle en rigole mais c'est pas
drôle
elle a pas pris deux fois des pions en
un qui était complètement gratuit elle
fit d'une pièce en un mois jeudi ban de
24 heures et mercedi commagnac pour pour
le prime moi je dis panne de 24 heures
non là tu vois c'est cela ce sera un ban
de 24 heures l'assureur
si on perd le match là sur un cette
battle clairement c'est du rhin
non mais tu peux pas perdre une partie
comme ça c'est juste que tu es mieux
quand même de a à z
tu es mieux de a à z mais tout d'un coup
d'envoi une pièce sans raison et tu
perds c'est dommage quoi
c'est dommage et dans les autres matches
du coup pour regarder un peu les scores
où ça en est par curiosité
arica qui mène c'était prévu que c'est
dieu qui mène c'était prévu ou chez nina
pour le moment nul on va voir on demande
à être surpris par des easy coréen
on verra on ne demande qu'à être surpris
les amis la kalach ça je crois qu'elle a
24 ou 25 ans
donc jeanneret
donc allez f6 décision as encore une
fois c'est mieux pour irina
tu apprendras aussi se prendre
réussissent donc à la paire de fou pour
les blancs c'est un petit plus c'est
peut-être une position qui lui convient
mieux
bon
comment tu vis avec les noirs t'échange
un cavalier tueur mais l'autre à la
place elle feu 5 elle joue actif elle
ouvre ça peut être dangereux contre les
fous je n'aurais jamais joué ça avec les
noirs mais a fait l'option isolé tout la
position du tout contre une paire de fou
mais après c'est son style alem bien
jouer actif il ya qui sera là pour le
soc battle
non mais tu restes que tu risque un jour
de bane un juriste 24 heures elliott en
fait il faut le savoir
tu risques un ban de 24 heures
dans croise est fourbe et 4 3 6
mouais ça peut se tenir quand même
donc toi c'est 8
well rial échange c'est bien joué en
fait ce qu'elle fait ça faisait un peu
peur d'ouvrir la position avec la paire
de fou mais du coup son roi va venir
colmater le pion de cavaliers actif elle
va la tenir sahara je pense je
m'inquiète même pour irina a vu qu'avec
m beaucoup plus forte à mon avis sahara
ça peut même être compliqué pour irina
à mon avis
fu b1 ça a commencé à partir entoure ces
six surtout reprend il y aura peut-être
baissé pour renforcer la tour qui part
en b 8 sél et noir qui peuvent commencer
à travailler ici qu'elle s'écarte aussi
wade en bullet c'est sarah favorite en
plus non mais je pense à la fabrique de
partout aujourd'hui en fait les matchs
sont pas très serré mais du coup ce sera
peut-être plus intéressant demain ou pas
ok elle tend un piège en fait elle veut
un moment donné sur tours c'est un tour
c'est 8 menacé cavaliers prend b2 n'y
aura pas tomber deux j'ai compris j'ai
compris où elle voulait en venir mais
elle veut tour c'est un cahier prend b2
menacé à tour sur ton premier temps
français sont en français si abc ouais
ça qu'elle voulait ça le petit piège
la master class de ce soir sera sur les
prix ont doublé
ouais non sarah elle joue bien
si c'est la tour c 5 puis relais j'avais
plein coït que les autres est en quelque
sorte sans quelques sa revanche sur les
pions qui seront sur la même colonne bon
alors ça c'est nul de chez nul mais bon
je peins peut jouer là tu veux tu as
peut-être envie de faire un roi aussi su
fort sur des cas très bon ça mène à rien
c'est quand même très symétriques
c'est souvent plus le joueur qui force
qui finirent par la cie finit par la
perdre pardon
sarah qui veut qu'il veut quand même
jouer pour gagner faut se méfier quand
même un faire gaffe l'a peut-être tour
des six est pas bête ouais c'est bien
joué tout reprend roi prend airois ces
cinq là jouent vraiment bien sarah je
trouve elle avait vraiment été mis sous
pression par auch et nina dans le
système de londres ce qui a écouté le
match mais elle aurait pu la battre
je pense qu'elle va prendre prendre et
roi des 5 1 mais roy prend des quatre
tours des 8
on ya paroisse et roya maths mais droit
peut monter et c'est à double tranchant
mais ça donne envie de jouer ça quand
même
mais il peut y avoir des a4 à un moment
donné se peut se retourner mais le truc
c'est que le roi blanc peut se retrouver
assez mal genre dans ce genre de
position par exemple le roi est vraiment
mal bon à laférois elle a joué un plan
différent
ouais ça peut se retourner ce que fait
le roi va venir en c3 la tour en d2 et
ça peut se retourner genre de trucs elle
en a trop fait sarah assez dommage hein
mais je faisais lycée souvent ça dans ce
genre de trucs peut-être offert 1 4 pour
essayer de faire tomber 10 à mleiha
tourbe et de tourbe et 4 c'est déjà fini
ouais c'est dangereux en vrai à laquelle
elle a trop voulu forcer
il n'y a pas vraiment de match
aujourd'hui à elliott c'est celui là qui
est peut-être le plus chaud en tout cas
la sarre acquis en mai du suspense dans
le match je vous avais dit en force et
ce genre de finale c'est extrêmement
dangereux
c'est terrible
ce terrible tomber 5,6 ouais ça a l'air
d'être le d'être un coup intéressant pas
qu'elles se fassent arnaquer c'est tout
tu reprends et en france et 4 à la plus
juste proposé nul au début de la finale
où la jouer plus tranquille 1 500 et des
propos y avait moyen de répéter la
position mais ce qu'elle a fait c'était
c'était une tentative passave du tout
voilà une jolie variante 3 au 5 par tout
de suite f 4 4 ou 6 matchs sympas du
cours arrive cette non sourcées s'être
arrachée 8
ça c'est désespéré et désespérant
serwa ck3 b5
4 pourquoi pas alors elle part de
l'autre côté j'ai dû rater un truc hein
elle veut rentrer comme ça mais là non
il ya roi ici ouais c'est fini 3g ça
rime bien joué de la part d'irina cette
partie là elle va la gagner c'est sûr
quoique quoique c'est plus si sûr que ça
du tout c'est loin d'être sûr qu'elle
gagne
ouais ça doit gagner maintenant je passe
à gagner tout le long et ça doit gagner
alala réseauter le roi en plus ton g8 il
faut hélas le roi va se rapprocher de la
tour c'est terminé bienvenue de la part
d'irina qui égalise et très mal joué de
la part de sarah si vous êtes une nulle
toriko avec k et h mais je peux me
rappelle jamais les cas de figure où ça
fait vraiment nul
bon écoute et le suspense reste entier
on va regarder le score des autres
matchs par curiosité
alors où china qui a pris lead kosteniuk
eux qui reste devant et arica qui écrase
pour le mans 2-0
donc ça a su un peu ce qu'on imaginait
on a bien choisi notre match cette
fois-ci
on la voit
enfin un échange avec des 4 c'est un
genre de gambie da avec des 4 retardée
en fait mais à un moment donné je joue
souvent tu finis par le jouer
à ce soir elliott qui nous quitte qui ne
souhaitent pas regarder ces match d'une
qualité exceptionnelle
alors qu'elle commença à continuer ici à
les d4 c'est jouer ça va échanger en d4
si elle gagne les pions un sahara si
elle prend les pions en inde ans est
parti il peut peut-être réussira à faire
quelque chose c'est qu'elle pourrait
déjà mené 2 0 1 au final si si elle
avait un poil mieux jouer elle pourrait
mener 2 0
finalement c'est elle qui a eu les
occasions dans toutes les parties 1
irina
du coup voilà le chien qui repart le
chat le chien qui repart il ya de
nouveau de nouveau une moto c'est
compliqué les motos il aime pas les
motos il n'aime pas
tu bosses dames ans et 8 rbds et 4 bons
times qui repart en d1
c'est une position très symétriques 1
les quatre matches et zéro surprise
maxime en fait quatre victoires large
par ailleurs cavale et b3 food et quatre
pouces et 5
t'as rien rater maxime absolument rien
rater c'est la bonne nouvelle c'est la
bonne nouvelle réunion des cinq têtes un
fou des quatre qui va arriver maintenant
il ya un fou prend g7 ah oui un franc g7
effectivement j'avais pas vu grand
projet 7 et à et d'amd 4 et roy j 6
dames feront b6 soit effectivement ça a
l'air sympa et dames des cats qui
marchait pas dans son sable ce qui a
fait 6 et essai le contre truc moi l'a
pas vu
je n'ai que quatre sur fou prend 4 elle
veut quoi veut d'armes trois faits
double attaque donc le fou qui va
repartir en a huit j'imagine
ou un fou g5 intermédiaire généralement
elles jouent pas de quoi intermédiaire
ouais
normalement elles font pas les cours
intermédiaire the past few g5 était bon
après un tas mettra en cas et 17 à la
part et la menace et e5
5 je n'aime pas trop ça ouvre le x 8 et
je vois pas ce que ça offre beaucoup
comme dame c'est de me donne envie
maintenant avec les noirs enfin mise à
part te mettre le pion sous pression je
vois pas trop ce que ça apporte
on va voir mais peu ça que j'ai vraiment
pas gérant pas trouvé ça très bon on va
voir où ça nous mène mais ça a l'air
sympa pour pour les noirs l faut qu'il y
ait en dessin qui fait une focale sur le
cavaliere elle joue vraiment pas pas
très très bien sarah dans ce match comme
gisèle appartient elle a vraiment
bénéficié des erreurs de d'irina la
partie de sa pas être exceptionnel non
plus elle avait fini par la paire dé la
partie iii elle fait elle fait pas grand
chose de bien finalement la rater le fou
prend g7 dont nous parlait maxime mellal
a fait ce f4 5 elle donne de la vie aux
pièces noires elle s'affaiblit
ça va peut-être faire nul après mais pas
terrible terrible c'est pas terrible
terrible et dans les autres matches du
conte pour jeter un oeil sur les scores
ou chimie nat 2-1 au sénat et demi 1/2
et arica 3 0 déjà
bon elle veut rentrer avec sa dame aussi
mais sont fous des quatre qu'il brille
beaucoup moins que le fou peut-être
cavaliers avec 8 kg 6 cavaliers h4 et on
mettra après le foin et fuit de faire
passer cavaler en premier c'est ce
qu'elle fait sur d'amd sur dame c'est ça
ta peut faire piéger 6 elle protégera
fois le métro est fuite allant vers le
cavalier à l'attack ça pourrait gagner 1
pour irene accroche
mais moi je préfère largement les noirs
maintenant
je préfère largement les noirs
maintenant bah ouais du coup l âge où
l'échangé d'un match où la nulle
maintenant elle sait bien jouer
ben non ça devrait aller quand même non
ça doit aller ça doit aller j'étais dans
le mood où les blancs jouent aussi pour
gagner j'ai oublié qu'elle pouvait faire
le switch est allé prendre le demi point
ce qu'elle devrait pouvoir réaliser
même si ce cavalier quand même bien hors
jeu complètement bloquée par le fou avec
la super focal
c'est terrible mais bon ça devrait ça
devrait suffire pour encaisser un demi
point
ça devrait être possible
on va voir comment ça continue ces deux
projets 6 qui a et b 3 ce que j'ai déjà
fait du compétitif tocard dînera ton
avis pour avoir le niveau que j'ai est
ce que j'ai déjà vu en compétition
réponse ah oui réponse b non aux
cardinaux à ton avis
bref 5 il est vrai que c'était 2300 mais
j'ai pas joué très longtemps jusqu'à 18
ans
et des grandes marques jouent pas en
compet lesquels j'en connais pas
personnellement
elle se fait dominer à 6 le fou a réussi
à rentrer voilà ça fait mal le cavalier
peut même plus être protégés
elle a fait un peu n'importe quoi ça
râle avec le 5 le machin et où elle joue
pas très bien en ce début de match
sahara alors qu'est ce qui peut nous
restait comme parti que c'est nous qui
fait l'écart et à la houle chez nina
alors son pseudo cn qui n'en attendent
pas enki on va aller chercher l'autre en
fait day
2580 c'est plus facile à trouver
on va les observer un peu la fin de
cette partie
on va se mettre du côté d'où chez nina
du coup côté blanc avec un nouveau
système de londres mais elle s'est
retrouvée elle se retrouve avec un pion
de moins fort comment s'est déroulé ce
truc là qu'est ce qui devient à richard
rapporte je sais pas tu voir les
meilleurs joueurs du monde mais paraît
que c'est pas un gros bosseur un cas la
file est le pion comme ça ce qui n'est
pas forcément toujours mauvais hein
parce qu'elle joue sur l'activité et son
adversaire qui est mal autant on va voir
les coûts qui vont défiler la d easy qui
n'a plus que 17 secondes
c'est maigre ou chez nina qui a réussi à
jouer vite et bien oui mais les caméras
mais daisy qui paraît un peu démoralisés
à la cam
tallieu 5 ceci le coup que j'aurais joué
puisque sur f6 tu peux avoir des cahiers
6 elle a peut-être fou b6 a essayé de
faire vous prend à cette flambée 5
c'est ce qu'elle joue
à cet effet tombé 5 mai loisirs qui a du
tour ces huit maintenant maillot puis on
prend encore plus fort peut-être
j'avais vu pousser 6 vous prendre
cavaliers prend ici pour ces sept on
reprend ainsi ce tour c'est 8 qui prend
1,7 on prend 1,7 pour à 3 revenir ans et
8 est tombée trois tout ce que j'avais
calculé ça tombe on assiste maintenant
on sait qu'il y avait lieu cette double
et sur la troisième et ramener le roi
mais ça donne rien pour les blancs voilà
peut-être ça donne roy f1 tout ces huit
tours b 6 3 et 2 3 3 et essayer de
choper le pion juste trois jours un peu
plus vite côté hanau chez nina elle peut
mettre la pression en fait ouais sur la
pendule adverse
je pense 3,3 maintenant et sur f5 n'ira
pas qu'il prend déjà les tours prend ses
3 et là y'a pas juste on apprend à non
il ya ça attaquait qui prend des huit à
vingt tours france et trois salles ils
ont fait retour b8 ici donc on va vite
qui est pro b 8 et revenir et c'est ce
qu'elle joue et revenir en c6 c'est
obligé et elle prend le pion mais encore
tour à tomber un pas tomber deux
étonnants je pensais qu'avec en b2
pourra essayer de gratter les pions anna
qui doit réussir à mettre la marche en
effet coutume à l'otan ana
mais bon elle l a prouvé jusqu'à jusqu'à
maintenant qu'elle pouvait jouer vite
elle a tour à deux ça va faire mal fait
tour à huit échecs en premier tour à 5
je pense qu'elle a joué avec tour à deux
tours à six salles attaque le pion voilà
mais tellement mal autant et allez
maintenant de pioncer qui doit partir
avec le pion des ça doit aller au bout
cette histoire ça c'est bien joué de la
part de d easy qui va la sauver croyable
assez chiant ah ouais donc on au sein
qui avait damé roi prend 1 500 g 5
fallait trouver g3 qui on prend qui on
prend tout reprend et on penser set mais
c'était dur et du coup à hanau chez nina
une nouvelle fois un des parties serrées
mais elle met les poings elle mène 3 il
reste peut-être encore chess queen
peut-être en jeu non elle se lève de
toute façon elle joue pas donc on va
faire une pause aussi on va voir le
score évoluer à rica qui mène 4 0 le
match est plié hanau chez nina elle va
plier le match c'est sûr elle est juste
plus forte et chez screen je sais pas
peut-être à le regarder l'autre partie
trois parties c'est aussi dans le
domaine du possible donc on va se mettre
de nouveau une petite pub on va se
passer cette partie en accélérant à est
une petite pub est echl est de retour
dans trois petites minutes
à la fin un peu avant la fin de la pause
mais là tout de suite les gars
alors les amis
alors partir pour la suite à risque sarr
jouent déjà non on va se remettre les
caméras non là c'était pas partie du
match c'est la dernière partie qu'on est
sûrs en entier stream fantômes et pièces
bouche tout sale exactement bon allez le
3 +11 reviennent passer une bonne
après-midi au high qui prend le tarot 1
va n'a pas le niveau juste à elle a
juste pas le niveau
c'est la deuxième fois qu'elle prend
cher mais à wayne on la sait c'est trop
fort en face
soissons dans les matchs je vous l'avait
ciblé comme un match qui serait facile
pour un ricard il car il joue bien c'est
étonnant qu'elle ait pas mieux joué
d'ailleurs dans l'eure dans l'autre
tournoi
arica ça joue bien mais vraiment là on
est sur la seule surprise un sahara qui
fait pas un grand match
bon après il ya un tel écart de niveau
qu'elle devrait pouvoir remonter mais
bon faut se méfier irina crush elle peut
elle peut être dangereuse quand même
elle peut être dangereuse
donc
juste afin par rapport au tournant il
sera au courant pour vendredi
pour qu'il sache un peu il ya panahi
musique zouk noël sera là dans le
prochain sisi 2014
le record de score c'est 11 01 est-ce
que c'est reparti alors à temps et ça
s'appelle voilà c'est en train de
repartir mais c'est pas le match qui
nous intéresse ce qui serait bien c'est
que ça nous envoie à la partie qu'on
veut c'est celle-là avec sarah en bas
c'est parfait chef d'état affable
donc on joue là même la même variante
que tout à l'heure de l'anim besoin d'y
être
c'est censé aller à cette finale pour
les noirs d'ailleurs sahara qui avait
une bonne position et qui finalement
avait un peu forcé ligue 1
donc
allez servir parti je n'ai juste à ce
qui est juste à femmes c'est un peu
changé le jeu profité pour l'écrire
c'est un peu changé le format sert
qu'avant ça reprenait à 16h les
deuxièmes matchs mais là ils ont ils
décalent ils attendent vraiment la fin
des premiers matchs pour reprendre
quel est le joueur qui a le plus
influencé son style de jeu dans un
deuxième temps sûrement shirov et salue
tard zolder
bonsoir à toi par bonjour à toi plutôt
unis cette heure là il faut encore un
grand grand soleil
d'ailleurs qu'est et 17 cavaliers qui va
revenir en d5 ça va bien se passer
bon le truc c'est que la structure
depuis avec les pions doublé le pion ans
et six en fait tu contrôles bien le
centre quand même avec les noirs et ça
se passe pas mal toujours du d4 chez les
joueurs pros ça dépend des joueurs et
des joueuses mais il ya moins de quatre
qu'avant parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
théories mais sut pas ce soir sur le
stream rouge jours et j'espère vers 19h
et j'espère voir un peu quelque chose
mais c'est pas sûr après autant aux
tendeurs de commentaire c'est pas
toujours facile mais moi je sais de
rejoint peu 4 les derniers temps du coup
j'essaye de me remettre à mon vrai
répertoire d'antan mais donc d'envoyer
du e 4 et des gourbis ouais mais des
cats est plus facile à jouer en beats en
fait au moins tu as ta petite partie et
tu t'es un peu en contrôle quoi battu
voilà c'est plutôt les blancs qui
pressent un peu c'est rien d'énorme mais
ça permet dé 4,7 permet d'être plus en
contrôle en blitz est vraiment bien sail
away de la rejouer avec 4 de remonter
avec 4 et de rejouer un répertoire un
peu à l'ancienne avec pas mal de gambie
des trucs un peu violent la grand roque
mais les noirs sont mieux un père de
fouler pions doublé qui vont disparaître
c'est terrible
terrible
fregat c'est pas forcément le coup de
l'année grand paris c'est logique quand
même pour mettre des pièces mettre une
tour sur la colonne des mails à sarah
qui joue beaucoup plus vite je pense je
pense que ça va vraiment faire l'écart 1
mais c'est important pour elle de gagner
la première partie pour pas avoir le
temps de douter celui de dca trouve ça
ennuyeux basse et plus stratégiques 1
c'est plus intéressant tout le fond de
court mais après jusqu'à un certain
niveau c'est dur
bref s'il revient dans les roues avant
le le pierre saint martin avant la
pierre saint-martin ouais faut pas
qu'ils se laissent distancer mais bon je
pense trop 17 tours des huit logique ya
peut-être des fous p3 qui peuvent être
intercalé à laisser plutôt bien quand
même
j'ai 5 pourquoi pas par moi j'aurais
fait grandir est pas perdu de temps avec
fougue et 4 avril à tous rendez-vous 800
a été vite vu mais je sais pas si
c'était mieux un tuk ou g5 à peut-être
faire pions prend ainsi un relief 4
écoutez il ya une logique pour ça qu'ils
doivent vraiment recoller au score à la
c'est comme jouer sa partie elle est
primordiale surtout qu elle al'avantage
si elle la rate ça va faire mal à la
tête
si elle gagne après elle revient
vraiment dans le match elle redevient
vraiment favorite du match mais me
regardez l'écart à la pendule quand même
une 27 contre 20 secondes
difficile pour rien n'accroche elle
accepte de jouer avec l'option de moi ce
que ce option évidemment il est condamné
un bon ça va demander quand même un peu
de technique encore pour aller noir mais
normalement vu le temps tension f5 quand
même elle attaque le foufou f3a et
surtout à deux via roi ou trois assez
peut-être qu'on ce qu'elle a fait et
surtout rejet troyat fou prend des cinq
avec un père tour sans b2f cinq tours b
3 tours francs désolé pour les travaux
encore une fois ça si un peu devant chez
moi
prise prises ou gk tour échec tours 4 ce
cas là gagne celle là ça doit pas être
gagnant
c'est marrant je pensais qu'elle allait
rester avec son roi sam et son
insupportable avec leurs travaux là
c'est impressionnant reste y avoir tour
b 3 à 5
ça va avancer à pont côté côté noir elle
va forcément tout tenté pour pour la
gagner près du tour des 4 as roi des six
tours d'un et tours 4 maintenant
peut-être à tour 84 kg on prend quatre
ça gagner je crois dommage avec autant
de temps m elle veut presser à la
pendule aller ça doit suffire
elle va gagner sa race et sur a3 p2b
quatre tours b2 pas assez de temps pour
irina b 3 ok peut-être à deux ans
première femme petit échec pour
reprendre du temps pour replacer la tour
ça montre le roi ça va mon temps des
quatre tours d1 et b3 elle fait b3 et
chaque direct et on prend des 3b 2a 2b
un bail c'est joli ça allez ça revient
elle égalise sahara on va regarder un
peu ce qui s'est passé dans les autres
dans les autres rencontres sahara qui
revient à rica qui creuse l'écart ou
chez nina qui creuse l'écart et
kosteniuk y creuse l'écart d'accords
donc ça va être le seul match
intéressant les amis de la de la journée
finalement pendant les travaux là c'est
un truc de ouf
là c'est un truc de ouf et travaux mais
comme je vous dis si je ferme je vais
bouillard deux shows donc désolé pour
les quelques minutes
là c'est terrible là c'est vraiment
terrible aujourd'hui l'armée c'est
vraiment un truc de fou c'est vraiment
un truc de fou
donc dames c'est ça être fou des deux
tours à c'est un fou un qui va être
jouée un peu comme dans les autres
partira jamais obtenu l'avantagé avec
les blancs ici un jeu c'est parce que
c'est la prépa de mathieu on va voir on
va voir la prépa de mathieu qui aura pas
été terrible pour pour sarah mais ok si
elle gagne stala et la prochaine qu'elle
met 2 0 ce qu'elle peut faire ça va ça
va être game 1 les amis s'arrête game de
chez game de chez game 2 chez game donc
pris dans des cas tu vas leur reprise en
d4 du pion elle a peut-être essayé de te
voir jouer pour des cinq rapide rock
j'imagine et peut-être des cinq classes
à tête être mieux comme ça puis on prend
car elle y prend qui prend fou prend
elle est quand même plus prête à jouer
pour ça donc allez peut-être pas si mal
elle a des cinq ça a l'air d'être sympa
ouais si on prend des 5 et prend des
cinq cas il prend des cinq francs des
cinq au moins le sera pas moins bien
elle prend pas de risque et ça va être
au noir de trouver les coûts là ce qu'il
ya déjà une menace assez fou france et 6
to france et 6 en france et 6 d'un
processus d'un premier set qui gagnerait
maintenant cette circulaire et où fin
les gars cette circulaire est juste
complètement ou c'est terrible c'est
terrible c'est terrible alors la fesfut
f6 alors est-ce qu'il va y avoir
cavaliers g5 et ce qui va y avoir dames
4 d'avocats tour 8 avoir d'avocat tour
e8 peut-être mercatour 8 peut être une
option
on va voir
ce que tu as me katz va être jouée ou g5
flessingue pas mal aussi parce qu'il se
libère la caf c2 pour la dame
éventuellement j'aime beaucoup g5
comprend le cinquième rang g5 tête h6
mais ce qu'il ya des dames ces deux qui
vont traîner des dames quatre des 44
c'est bien joué ça avait tellement de
pression sur son adversaire mais bon je
vais fermer la fenêtre j'en ai marre de
la personne désolé les gars ce micro est
en fait pour pas prendre les bruits
extérieurs vous l'entendez beaucoup
moins que ce que je l'entends moi il y
en a marre bon là il ya juste damage
cinq noms allez encore h6 ya encore h6
pardon haye adam h 5 h 6/4 aliev sait
tous rêvent cette fois vii d'un fcf
d'art fc3f sait-on 17 ont flambé cette
baisse à sentais qu'il y avait quelque
chose l'a vu le placement des pièces
à dammaj 5 c'est game direct en fait
d'un match 5 c'est game direct comme
c'est hyper facile avoir acheté ce qui
précède c'est élémentaire 1 avec tours
17 à la fin ça c'est élémentaire
ouais bah c'est sûr qu'à aller voir
c'est fini tout de suite
ouais ça y est elle fait elle fait
l'écart
sarah sais plus ce type de match auquel
on s'attendait
voilà c'est sûr qu'à aller le voir c'est
élémentaire pour des clauses de ce
niveau là et c'est fini du rhin pour
irina mais méritée pour sarah qui joue
beaucoup mieux
taki qui a déjà gagné match la semaine
dernière et qui jouent généralement
mieux alors là c'est ici c'est eux qui
on peut faire du tour france et 6
peut-être déjà apprend fou prend tout
reprend fou prend mais le problème c'est
que d'un point f2 ne peut être on
commence par g3 et sur da mais si son
aura peut-être fou prend fou prend tour
des six hockey au pire en a final avec
un ou deux pions de plus j'ai 3 semble
avoir une certaine logique ça va enlever
les vagues du couloir aussi bas c'est ce
qu'elle fait c'est logique en vrai
maintenant h 4s est logique aussi elle
veut carélie g53 je suis ta loire faire
cavalier set je pense quoique elle peut
aussi prendre fait juste source et 2
ouais il y avait le pion à défendre par
ben ouais ça semblait pouvoir se gagner
sur le champ
elle va prendre les tours des six images
in adam preuve de assez terrible damev
farouche 2 n'y avait pas toi de mal
puisque la tour était cloué 1
pour ceux qui pensaient voilà surtout
paroisse g8 ya qui prend injustices dont
croivent 703,7 seul coup c'est la vue
bien sûr d'un même cinq prises prises et
tour c'est donnant à tous un échec
d'abord pour ça et change maintenant b3
lecavalier loin par rapport aux pions
faire bouger ce cavalier avec les blancs
le roi qui monte dans la voie lactée
trois des quatre
à 3 pts 1 4 à 3 et 10 et 2 mais là elle
va être mieux sarah surtout à plus de
temps pour irina 3,5 ce terrible roi
prend 1,6
irina qui craque j'aurais mimran bessède
plus tôt mais ça a l'air d'être très
bien comme ça aussi il y avait peut-être
un g4 échec intermédiaires qui était
intéressant mais le cavalier peut pas
revenir c'est terminé difficile pour
irina mais c'est perdu
et ça fait 3 2 et ça fait 3 2 les amis
le score le score qui est qu'ils aient
pris par prix par sarah sahara qui prend
le lead alors les autres matches à 5 1
pour ou chez nina 4-0 pour gears ya 5 0
pour table pour abraham yann web on est
on est sur le seul match intéressant les
gars de toute la journée on a bien
choisi notre match irina irina forcément
dans le dur mais aussi l'impact
psychologique d'or perdu la semaine
dernière voilà quand même été bien aller
dominé le début de match et elle s'est
bien fait contre et donc
une robe qui allait tourner 8 à la voir
jouer le cavalier sur quatre je vais
pourtour c8 c5 ou pour qu'arras lieu
quatre fous des six de plans possibles
ces six aussi possible elle se blinde et
du coup à tour ses huîtres est peut-être
fou des six maintenant pour ses sets
elle vous faire quoi j'ai pas trop où
elles vont en venir là avec les noirs
parce que dans ma vie se fait plus trop
sens la tour ans et 7 elle est bizarre
c'est un peu bizarre et je ne sais pas
c'est pas spécialement grave mais c'est
un peu bizarre la construction pour moi
ce qu'elle fait après c'est peut-être
très bon et je connais pas je préfère
pas je trouve le four est en baisse est
étrange mais elle veut pas jouer b5
maintenant elle dame à 8
ok juste il ya quelque chose qui est
bizarre pour moi parce que qui est a
quand même j'ai pas l'impression que
elle joue dans le bon ordre mais en fait
c'est être pas mal
peut-être db5 1 peuvent être
intéressants pour essayer de faire kébé
6-4 mais juste la dame en a 8 elle
paraît tellement hors jeu je pas ce que
vous en pensez
non c'est à qui tu peux pas avoir la
réponse sur ce genre de trucs il faut
vraiment analyser soi même en profondeur
ouais à 5 maintenant ok ça ça fait sens
au moins elle a réussi à retrouver du
lion un peu dans ses pièces
on va voir québec 4 je sais pas la
partie je la trouve bizarre en soi
peut-être qu'à relief 6 c5 maintenant
pour jouer là bas qui est pions pendant
tous ces pièces dans la même petite
pièce ouais c'est un peu bizarre mais
l'anc a damé en a 5 et où elle fait ses
cinq direct et sur pions prend pions
prend cavaliers prend elle va vouloir
faire un c4 attaque la dame ait joué là
dessus
j'imagine à irina qui peut se reprendre
le tarif encore une fois c'est terrible
nice est 4ème et ses 4 comment tu vois
passer quatre fini à méroé fuite assez
triste 1 c'est euro à prendre cette voie
n'a pas aidé à l'appât du loir en fait
perdre juste une pièce en ligne elle
craque complètement et irina pardon j'ai
vu tempo sans ordi qui est prend 1,5 et
d'un prend 1,5 à l'as pas vu non plus à
la fabula dames 45 ans la belle a tout
donné et rida ça y est elle a craqué
physiquement la halle a craqué
physiquement elle est en sur régime 1
pour tenir le le rythme de sarah et là
elle a craqué dame c3 le rockeur partir
en fuite
je pensais à mettre l'option ces trois
heures pas s'embarrasser sayal à craquer
rina
ça va faire plus deux pour sarah kane f5
attaque la tour sur tours là elle a
peut-être même un cavalier prend 3 qui
marche c'est rare avec un roi au centre
que ça marche les sanctions est
tellement fort
[Musique]
et a fini par perdre son pion quand même
papa était clean clean clean sahara mais
ça doit suffire
disons qu'il faudrait qu'à leurs maîtres
sont rois à l'abri je pense des trois
fuites
on va voir un irina qui tente d' arnaque
est fou dessins qu'elle va faire pousser
4 maintenant à alès le pion à vii
c'est une grosse gaffe c'est encore un
pouce et quatre salles et c'est le plus
haut si c'était pas bon je m'en suis
rendu compte au monde le dire
c'est pour ça que j'ai tout de suite eu
fou prend d'un bref cette très grosse
faute mais bon elle a de la réussite
peut-être que peut-être dame g5
maintenant menace mater couvrait assez
bien ça et maintenant damage 6 c'est
bien au delà match 6 sa force c'est sa
et la finale et gagner facile bizarre de
ne pas avoir fait elle préfère filer des
pions mais elle menace mat
elles menacent le fou dame g7 qui va
être roi des 8,3 c7 est maintenant qu'à
relief cet allant même pas elle va aller
jusqu'en à 7m elle donne d'un f4
maintenant mais bon il y aurait eu un
roi à 7 quand même et ça et je pensais
qu'elle voulait faire droit à cette es
fou bessette
bon ça gagne quand même et ça va
enchaîner les amis dans la cadence
sahara qui domine complètement le match
il n'y a pas de y'a pas de souci
là-dessus
terrible hein y'a plus de parties la non
scission quoi ça reprend pas je vais
aller checker je vais aller de chez
qu'est ce qu'il en est en terme de
timing ce qu'on prouvera premiers pas de
parti qui repartent là où c'est moi qui
ai un bug temps les attendait non non il
reste encore six minutes
il ya un bug pourtant je la suivrai non
voilà ça y est c'est reparti
donc
je regarde juste en plus pour les scores
les américains qui suivent le match puis
à cinq et demi un ennemi c'est terrible
c'est terrible le stream america ici le
match qui est déjà fini c'est fou bon en
tout cas ce match qui est toujours en
cours et on peut dire que c'est des
quasi balle de match pour pour sa fin il
faut qu'elle gagne encore 2 parties sur
sur 5 pour être sur un ennemi sur 5
puisque je gagne facile contre les deux
non je pense pas du tout bien loin de là
alors après en longue elle me bat toutes
les deux très facilement dans le format
qui est comme dans le speech est ce au
vu des lots qu'elles ont sur czech comme
je serais quand même favori mais en
longues à elles sont elles me bats en
sang sans aucune difficulté 1
donc non pas du tout après en bits sur
internet sûrement oui mais
mais ces deux choses bien différentes un
cdd décadence et de jeu complètement
différent
le blitz sur internet et les longs gants
sur échiquier sait s'il ya vraiment une
grande différence 1 c'est vraiment pas
la même chose
c'est vraiment pas la même chose du tout
tout ça râlait vraiment très très forte
en longues en général et l'effort juste
être sur l'échiquier en 2d à la plus de
mal mon a l'habitude
six langues j'arrive pas à l'ong
si je me remettais d'après les pertes
que j'ai fait quand j'ai recommencé jeu
pour arriver à 23 40 23 50 tu vois mais
elles sont plutôt 24 50 25 dons
recueillis à 100 150 points d'écart donc
tu vois ça veut dire que sur dix parties
doivent me bats et ennemis 2000 quelque
chose comme ça je crois à peu près à
quelque chose près à quelque chose près
je veux vraiment bien quand je veux pas
monter à 2001 non non non jamais de la
vie impossible
si je voulais monter à 2005 en longues
il faudrait que je met ma vie en
parenthèses pendant deux trois ans et
peut-être que j'aurais une chance
et encore c'est loin d'être sûr mais
c'est à minima
mais bon je vais pas arrêter ma vie
pendant 2-3 enfin j'ai d'autres trucs à
faire coiffer un fou je m'en fous d'être
2005 en longues ou pas très concrètement
enfin sa lancia pas fou prend 1 h 6 6 6
puis on prend et des six tu démoli le
rock et tutus cloud et en glissant un
blitz away en beach pourrait peut-être
faire au moins 2004 c'est sûr et
peut-être 2050 en travaillant un petit
peu a fait caca c'est bizarre de rater
si c'est des six canes non mais oui
c'est fin tu as les parties donc j'ai
donné plus de dix ans de ma vie à ça et
j'ai plus envie quoi ça m'intéresse plus
quoi ça m'intéresse juste plus j'en ai
assez fait déjà je m'amuse pas donc
c'est pour moi c'est un travail en fait
de jouer en mode
c'est d'ailleurs une des raisons pour
lesquelles je suis moins fort fait lever
de s'amuser c'est vraiment important
quand tu fais quelque chose que moi pour
moi aller en jouer des parties longues
comme vous allez au travail le matin
quoi ça me fait chier
donc c'est déjà un problème
après faire un répertoire d'ouvertures
ça me fait chier aussi fabien jouant
longue c'est vraiment un travail c'est
ça ne m'amuse pas en fait tu me
demandais ce que je préfère blitz et
vous allez à la plage je vais te dire
oui tu sais tu me demandes se réfère à
la plage ou en longue je préfère aller à
la plage tu as faim de très très loin
est ce que je préfère donner un cours
d'échecs où joue une partie longue
je préfère largement donné un cours
d'échecs fin partie longue en fait pour
moi c'est cédant 1 rennes jld de trucs
que j'aime pas du tout faire en fait
c'est dans leur haine je descende les
poubelles tu vois ça relou elle va faire
des six cavaliers ainsi cédé 7 là elle
n'a pas raté cette fois ci elle va
gagner à ça
ouais tu arrives faire le ménage aime
pas trop non plus tu vas faire la
vaisselle jouets des parties longues
ailes à 17 c'est bien jouer cavalier
prend angels jolie dame ces six
cavaliers six bons fruits adam problème
si ce qu'ils gagnent mais juste pour
montrer ça arrive souvent ce genre de
pointe à la fin du ku'damm des huit mais
là il ya surtout que sur 17 à la fée
d'amd 8 mai la dame prend f7 et c'est
game 1 ça doit être game jouable je la
vois pas trouvé un coup ici sarah du
goût qui va prendre trois points
d'avance et qui va tuer le match phare
wah wah wah quelque part et tournoi est
maintenant dame j'ai ici c'est tour 8
ok toi aussi serait bien aussi mastour
g6 et dames f7 et je sais pas quoi ou
menacent toujours d'amener six tours 8
un carton g63 cette dame fc3a je suis
tout rejet cette dame g7 oui et c'est
gagné pour sarah je pense c'était la
dernière partie pour elle dans la
cadence on va regarder les scores des
autres matchs hanau chez nina 6 2 6 1
5-1 alors d easy est ce que ça joue
encore parce que ça pourrait être mon
cas on peut un peu regarder ce qu en
gros les autres matches valence et finit
par tout en fait en vrai il ya aucun
suspense aujourd'hui c'est terrible
c'est terrible les avis
ses dribbles temps mais ça aujourd'hui
ambühl est sûre il sur les huit matches
en fait y en a aucun qui a été serré
c'est quand même incroyable non c'est
rarement ou c'est moi qui divague
c'est rare quand même sur rue sur huit
matches d'avoir aucun match un peu serré
au moins n'a pas eu un seul c'est au
début de la phase de bulle est on a
regardé le seul où il y avait que deux
points d'écart et il ya eu trois points
d'écart directement
il ya eu zéro match serré aujourd'hui
c'est la première fois je crois mais pas
de surprise en plus c'est pas serré
c'est toujours les favoris qui ont gagné
très facilement
bon ben ça va peut-être nous promettre
des matchs intéressants demain why
cruche ces prix a crush s'est fait
cracher elle s'est pris 5-0
et ça les antonymes annoncé durant ce
terrible ces terres qui fut difficile
aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui c'est difficile
les cartes seront peut-être plus engagés
ouais on espère ou pas d'ailleurs
un temps pisté pas engagé c'est un plus
c'est une premier tour m et dans les
autres complète dans les autres tournois
puis c'était celle mêmes tournant à
chaque fois les premiers toit était un
peu qu'il y avait un match serré à
chaque fois où une surprise ou quoi mais
aussi wii après faut avouer qu'on a eu
des matches serrés à cause des
déconnexions aujourd'hui les connexions
bien tenu c'est réussi on est le
problème de ne plus avoir de défaite sur
des connexions et ça coûte cher ça ça
nous aura coûté cher que les joueuses et
une bonne connexion savais qu'il y avait
eu joué john key avait réussi avec suez
qui avait perdu des partis sur des qu il
y avait eu lifan qu'il y avait une
connexion en bois donc du coup il ya des
partis qui a été perdu et saint rémy la
pression
du temps du montage aurait peut-être un
jour ce type de tournoi c'est rld sorte
de grand talent aussi
ban en seniors du coup
bon à voir ce qui se passe dans cette
partie samuel sarr en pls du tutu format
aussi qua non honnêtement le formage
comprends vraiment pas à parler on en
parle pour la dixième fois aujourd'hui
mais je n'arrive pas à comprendre en
fait à quel moment on a pensé que
c'était bien de faire ça je sais pas à
quel moment en fait à une réunion et les
gens s'ils ont organisé quatre fois le
même trois d'affilée c'est c'est bien je
sais pas comment c'est possible en fait
c'est je sais pas je ne sais pas je
n'arrive pas ça me ça me dépasse
complètement fait je sais pas je n'ai
pas les mots en fait c'est est ce que si
daisy prend là newscan dommage
c'est la psychologie inversée un terrain
non mais vraiment je n'ai pas les mots
en fait je trouve ça fait une mauvaise
pub pour le pour le truc quoi ces
dommages faits à l'idée du truc féminin
il est bien de faire un évène féminin
c'est très très bien et que des femmes
j'aime beaucoup l'idée en vrai mais
juste la réalisation c'est je me demande
comment tu peut empirer le truc en fait
c'est ça ce serait dur en fait de
s'asseoir et se dire comment faire pire
c'est dommage que assez pour ça en fait
que je pousse à 6 dommage mais il ya
peut-être là gagner ça d'ici qui joue
pas mal en vrai un pays qui joue
vraiment pas mal je trouve
elle est menée mais à chaque fois qu'on
vient sur une partie n est pas si mal
acquis mais anna qui joue bien dans les
designers et joue vite aller daisy c'est
bien dès qu'il a senti le défi qui sent
les échecs
allez c'est bien ce que fait des il a au
nom croit alors qu'ils pouvaient venir
ans et six à ces terribles anna qui
s'est trompé mais avec si peu de temps
sur la pendule finalement c'est du rhin
c'est difficile peut pas lui en vouloir
quelques secondes au chronomètre
c'est jamais évident imposition est pas
si simple que ça mais allah qui tombe un
peu craqué mais bon elle trois points
d'écart un scan très confortable ça
devrait largement suffire
cherpion inédit fois le même toit a de
suite fait tomber c'est tellement
dommage en fait et il aurait pu faire un
loser bracket où ce genre de trucs
j'ai voulu que ça dure un peu plus avec
seize joueuses ou même avec 20 joueuses
se faire un truc avec un loser bracket
où machin fayat il y avait pas mal de il
y avait moyen de faire un truc qui dure
un peu plus longtemps mais avec quelque
chose de bien ou des poules ou quoi il y
avait quand même de matière il y avait
quand même matière
faire quelque chose de bien
ces genres et puis d'un coup et fument
sont violentes
bon donc ya la petite pause l'arrêt
après ça va reprendre pour les dix
dernières minutes
ce sera parti pour les dix dernières
minutes et on se retrouvera demain à
14h30
pour la suite c'est beau
c'est beau c'est beau mais demande à
voir de meilleurs matchs ça sera mieux
demain c'est sûr enfin sur
rien n'est sûr mais possible
je trie murray ce soir un petit peu plus
tard moussa sow et âme à sa place de
femme tout à l'heure
costinha coucher ni na waie sera
peut-être un beau match ça non mais
demain il y aura des beaux matches c'est
sûr qu'en fait là toutes les plus
faibles se font éliminer donc demain il
y aura des beaux matches demain il y
aura forcément des beaux matchs parce
que ce qu'on fait à riga sarah kosteniuk
et ou chez nina c'est les plus fortes
qui passe et tout à l'heure koné roule
haguenau joue à une jounée oui fans
c'est les plus fortes qui sont passés
aussi
donc là on devrait y avoir un beau
tableau on a les affiches jouaient ce
serait trouvable mais moi je les ai pas
là actuellement dans le sens où là
encore c'est pas organisé dans le bon
ordre ou aller les joueuses du même
tableau joue pas en même temps
donc du coup on s'y perd et les quarts
de finale vois tu vas y aller premier
qui rentrent donc on peut peut-être et
on verra après mais dans tous les cas ça
fera des beaux matches mais ça joue en
croisé en fait c'est s'ils jouent en
premier sont pas celles qui jouent en
deuxième fin ne joue pas avec celle qui
joue en deuxième
en tous les cas ça va repartir bientôt
alors on va se remettre les scores nous
en attendant pour voir que c'est pas les
bons scores pour voir si sarah de façon
si sarah en gagnes tu nous fais une
nulle et que ou chez nina en gagnant
nous fait une fête ont besoin d'une
nulle
le match est plié quasi direct on va
voir on va voir si voilà la 3 3 points
honnêtement en dix minutes c'est surtout
vu les écarts de niveau
vu que c'est les favorites qui mène
c'est un remontable je pense ok je
donnerai une chance sur cent qu'on est
une surprise dans un des deux matchs à
un retournement
je donnerai une cote à ce sens mais pour
dire que ou cruijff est ori l'emportent
je pense elle serait la côte normale
sans contrat
je dirais ça
on va voir un je voudrais une cote à 100
parce que j'y crois pas du tout j'y
crois pas du tout je vois pas dans quel
monde corrie mais 3 0 ou chez nina ou
crush mais 3-0 à ça bon on va voir un
maire c'est mon prono après ça vaut ce
que ça vaut
ça vaut ce que ça vaut
les candidats c'est quand va écouter
essayer de le faire en septembre octobre
mais vu la la situation avec la pandémie
j'ai bien peur ça puisse pas reprendre
de sitôt rhin aime beaucoup d'endroits
dans le monde qui sont encore qui sont
encore en sueur j'ai du mal à croire à
un retour rapide des candidats après
j'espère me tromper sa vaisselle
directoire ouais bah ça avec la vue qui
a parlé en cette période il ya que des
toits sur internet c'est dommage de ne
pas avoir repris les arénas king et ce
genre de truc qui était un peu hype ans
pour tout le monde qui permettait aux
gens de stream et de s'amuser tout ça et
d'avoir d'avoir vouloir faire des copier
coller des mêmes tournois tout le temps
c'est un peu dommage se trouve mais bon
c'est comme ça c'est pas nous qui
décidons en même temps
c'est pas nous qui décidons s'arrêter
peut-être plus cool de faire plus
d'événements un peu comme le poc chaîne
pourquoi qu'ils soient plus à originaux
et qu'ils puissent marcher que sur
internet
alors allez c'est reparti mais si on
n'est pas sur le bon match on va essayer
de récupérer le bon match ouais voilà
c'est le match de sarah balle et on va
voir donc
victoire obligatoire pour pour green
accroche comme je vous disais en cas de
nul il ya une micro chance encore de
revenir mais elle est très mince jouer
quatre partis c'est rarissime dans cette
cadence de bullet en cas de défaite
c'est directement finito donc ça rejoue
ceni mesure indienne pendant ici dans
les esprits tarrach là où ça les change
tout la tour qui va arriver ans et 8
rapidement on va voir ce que ça donne
l'époque c'était vraiment un opus nous
dit chassez lowey mais au moins c'était
quelque chose de différent là il perd
des fois des idées de prendre prendre
prendre et cavaliers des 5 peut parfois
exister pour jouer sur ce clou âge ou
prendre prendre et carré des cinq gheit
bon alors
quelqu'un est quand même venu en a 5
c'est quand même pas mal hein bon c'est
pas mal pour les blancs pour le moment l
échange elle veut se gagner la casse ces
six caisses noires sont mal placés à
l'oeil rina qui va qui va peut-être
surprendre une première fois déjà parce
que là c'est avec les noirs sont mal
elle va échanger à elle veut partir et
cavaliers g7 car il y avait cinq
affaires qui a je pense que l'afrique
ait g7 où la source et kg cette course
et 8
d'accord elle veut chasser la tour très
très mal à ça elle est extrêmement mal
il ya dame c8 qui a un coût et dame
prend pour francky g7 ours et c'est tout
là ouais là ça va ça va faire très mal
les amis on va essayer d'aller naviguer
avec lecavalier mais elle pleurait elle
s'est fait complètement dominé sarah son
cavalier à plus de cases elle a même pas
tour 17 la tour c 8
elle va se prendre a4 a5 a6 voilà ça
râle a aucune chance à l'est irina qui
qui va relancer un peu le match 1 mais
peu à peu quasiment y avoir abandon de
la part de sarah mais qui essaye encore
de lutte et essayer de créer la baie 6b
7b huit ans sarah tsahal à sa file tout
seul
pas besoin de trop hésiter bien jouer
des changes est inquiet sur but avec à
ypres ambiguïté il n'y a pas de bonnes
pièces pour reprendre à faire tour des 3
4 et 4 17 buts dame qui avait les prends
tous reprendre des 3c d'échangés elle
veut jouer le plus longtemps possible ce
qu'elle se dit peut-être qu'il peut y
avoir que deux parties dans la cadence
agyenin mais c'est tout c'est tout à
fait normal
surtout que bon la partie et gagnante et
gagner mais en bullet on a vu des trucs
très spéciaux notamment la semaine
dernière avec l'agglo qui a manqué un
+15 très simple en finale donc c'est
normal et légitime là pour sarah pour le
monde joue encore un peu c'est normal et
lucie voyage à 51 coups dans la partie
normalement ça t'empêche pas d'avoir
trois parties dans la cadence de toute
façon donc ml ce même à l'otan elle se
met mal autant irina ou là le père le
pion bêtement là ou là là là là c'est en
train de s'arrêter à ton projet café
papattes ce terrible
elle a voulu tenter le pat c'est raté à
l'abandonnent et donc ça fait 1 0 donc
là la chose qu'on sait dans le dans le
bullet
bon maintenant la chose dont on est sûr
les amis c'est qu'il y aura pas plus de
trois parties alors ou chez nina qui a
gagné le match s'est fait d'accord donc
c'est le dernier match qui peut se
passer quelque chose
allez il faut que kirin a la gagne là
c'est victoire obligatoire pour toutes
les parties elles obligées de gagner ses
chaussures
on va voir si elle y arrive avec les
noirs elle a eu des positions correct
dans ce match il faut qu'elle continue à
avoir ses positions à la gagner
donc il ya un pion plus pour laurent
pour les blancs mais il va tomber en c5
écoutez c'est pas fait encore un c'est
pas fait pour pourrir ocz cas pour sarah
pardon érotique à la 83 qui peut revenir
dans le match aller 3 h 1 re 4,5 là en
bullet ces genres de choses que tu as
envie de faire elle fait à 3 d'abord
pour éviter
mais maître laurent h1 je pense ça mange
pas de pain
foulant fief de une autre un autre plan
dans le du même acabit ouais c'est ce
qu'elle fait c'est ce qu'elle fait est
ce qu'il va y avoir du 4 maintenant
quand je vous disais un nul nul permet à
sa rade de gagner le match
si elle fait nul c'est game il reste il
reste combien de temps à cannes on sait
ce qu'est ce que même mieux que est-ce
qu'il ya mieux que nulle pour ed
c'est à dire perdre une partie longue
une partie qui dure est-ce que même ça
ça pourrait suffire ou pas est-ce que
même ça ça pourrait suffire ou pas il
reste combien de temps non il reste
trois minutes cinquante ans il reste il
restera forcément une partie derrière
celle là voire même deux d'ailleurs sur
celle-là se conclure rapidement
ah ouais donc c'est pas s'il fait fait
fait que ça un pur pour sarah qui
semblait tellement dominé le match joué
plus vite mais mais qui retombe un peu
dans ses travers du début de match on
pensait on pense et irina genou à terre
un après avoir pris un 4-0 compliqué
mais a l'impression que ça devenait dur
dans toutes les ouvertures finalement
finalement dans ce dans cette cadence
bullet hell revient un petit peu ces
deux sahara qui doit savoir que le que
le match nul est en sa faveur
elle refait 5 comme tout à l'heure à
peut-être fait un petit fou h cette
fougue 4a les menaces faim menacent pas
mat mais met une pression ici côté
côté irina sahara qui veut vraiment
échanger les dames iryna évidemment qui
refusent sahara qui attend on se
rappelle que tard dans une position un
peu similaire finalement sarah avait
pris les devants droite c'est de ne pas
avoir pris ici sur d'un point et
mesdames pro f 4 bon allez ça il se
passe il se passe pas grand chose les
joueuses qui répètent les noirs qui sont
sûrement mieux qu'ils ont peut-être le
roi blanc a peut-être un poil plus
faibles fipar entré dans la finale où la
salle elle paraît vraiment difficile à
gagner
c'est dommage qu'elle n'ait pas pu faire
l'effort dans le milieu de jeu mais bon
quand même à ce type y ont eu cinq là le
roi qui monte
il ya des petits fous c'est un qui
traîne
il va falloir mettre la pression la côte
et irina est la finale un vrai fou prend
f3 n'est pas si simple 1 3 5
est ce que le royer s'est pas
complètement trompé de deux territoires
est fou 3 bref quatre j'aime bien là ce
qu'elle fait roi g3 elle va gagner irina
droit prend fou ici fonds f2i ou comme
ça et c'est quoi être un gagnant
incroyable
sarah quittent choc foulée deux fous
prend et le plus bref qui part
incroyable j'ai donné côte de son
contrat bon elle n'a pas encore gagné le
maintien mais incroyable à les amis
qu'est ce qu'elle fait ah non non non il
ya eu un lac du site où là le site qui à
l'ags et c'est pas ma connexion internet
c'est la connexion aux serveurs avec
czech comme alors il n'y a plus que toi
il ya plus qu'un point d'écart c'est la
dernière partie et irina qui fait une
remonte à la terrible 2-0 dans le bullet
en ayant bien dominé les deux parties on
va voir si ça a réussi à recoller au
score
enfin romain remettre à remettre un coup
de collier là parce que ça se passe pas
très bien coté côté sarah messiah
l'ouverture à l'année mieux sorti elle
réussit à reprendre le contrôle du
central mais bien les cavaliers c4 elle
enferme le fou ou à la elle semble avoir
remis un coup de pression là ça
adam sept ou huit cavaliers e4 on va
jouer contre le fou de cases noires ça
paraît vraiment très compliqué pour
irina cette partie l'ouverture l on
n'est pas très bien sortie la ja b 4 qui
va arriver le cavalier qui va jaillir
sur détroit ça paraît extrêmement
extrêmement difficile pour la joueuse
américaine
l'iranienne qui va peut-être mettre un
pion en b3 mais bon le fou qui revivra
verser 1 pour à pouvoir repartir vers
verges et cinq s'est pas encore c'est
pas encore fait f34 et les deux pions
les deux pions centraux qui avance
qu'elle prend des quatre dames f2 bien
joué elle met la pression sur le
cavalier il ya eu 5 qui va partir il ya
le pion à vii
on est en train de on est en train de
vivre une énorme surprise un coup de
fringale là pour pour sarah le match
était trop facile pour la joueuse
iranienne et tout d'un coup le pion qui
va partir en eux cinq là mon avis et
d'un premier set
allez c'est parti qu'avec des cinq dames
prend fc 3 h 8 ème et bizarrement
lecavalier 6 6 1 to hell cavaliers des
cinq attaques le fou où elle s'en sort
bien la sarre à olaya dame b 6 échecs
cavalli france et trois à ces terribles
les amis à le contre à terrible pour
pour la joueuse américaine
il y aura encore tourné six enfin deux
variantes peut-être améliora dames c'est
cette ok ya peut-être encore moyen food
etc attaque et prend des 4 donc ça ça a
l'air d'être des trideau salaires des
durées roi chain qui les prend ces trois
noms elle parcourt food et 4 et prend
des quatre dames f2 il n'y a pas qu'à
valliot deux échecs mais puisqu'à car il
y prend aux deux pardon j'avais dix-sept
cette bêtise un peu plus tôt tout
reprendre 5 adam f8 d'accord donc elle
va récupérer quand même le cavalier
s'est pas assez pas fait fait plus de
vingt secondes pour sarah les amis c'est
en train de c'est en train de se décider
là ce match le cai qui revient ces six
mille ans n'y adam prend cavaliers prend
et et tour des six donc ça échange ya
quoi dans la finale il ya finale pour un
pion de plus pour les noirs ouais ça ça
quand même ça c'est quand même bien
transformer la côte et sarah qui est des
trois qui menacent tête des tours aux 20
h 3 to run quand même roitg de il reste
plus que 16 secondes penser il faut pas
jouer pour le nul avec les noirs parce
que ça peut ça peut tourner avec si peu
de temps 6 il annule s'offrent à toi
prends la messine on ne la prend pas là
il ya le pion à 5,8
bon ben ça va faut prendre à cinq mètres
la tour angers 4e et tours à cet ol va
la perdre ça elle va la perdre tour à
sept tours à huit et tour à 7 c'est très
bien joué de la part d'irina tout
reprend g7 ont g7 ont gelé cette scéne
m'attend 3 incroyable sarah qui perd au
nom elle rate le matin elle rate
maintenant deux ans c'est terrible oh
c'est terrible elle a raté ma temps deux
au non franchement il est scolaire
celui-là est ce qu'elle va savoir gagner
roi de pions contre contre contre tours
leroy de pions tour elle est assez
facile cette finale mais va pas falloir
va pas falloir se tromper quand tu as
raté ma tondeuse quand même c'est
terrible c'est terrible on se prépare
pour les cette battle de demain là les
amis il reste plus de temps dans ce
match il faut absolument qu'elle gagne
qu'elle gagne maintenant les pions qui
vont avancer c'est élémentaire à gagner
va y avoir juste une petite manoeuvre
avec le roi allez la tour c 8 3 bougez
g6 dont tout reprend tour c 'est 3 3 je
suis terroir pranger 6e tour prend g7 là
ça doit quand même aller voilà c'est de
nouveau un lac je pense ouais c'est un
petit lac de duchess comme et ça à
gagner c'est incroyable les amis c'est
sarah qui fera sarah la cotation contrat
là qui est en train de tomber
incroyable c'est incroyable il va y
avoir deux parties la en 2d partage
ouais c'est incroyable de s'être fait
remonter comme ça les amis moncassin mon
cas est dans le chatt mon kite berly
sandales à lacets là c'était là c'était
le ban 72 heures la voilà quand on a
parlé de ban 72' route band aid tout à
l'heure c'était sur des performances
comme celle là ça me réussit le match
n'est pas encore gagné 1 c'est pas fini
ça mais oui j'ai dit si le sait sans
contrat pour qu'une des deux gagne le
match
là y'a que égalité sahara qui peut
encore l'emporter mais c'est vrai que
c'est quand même irina a maintenant
qu'il ya le qui a l'ascendant
psychologique
la sara qui mérite le ban de 72 heures
sur une perf comme ça et même la défense
du roi tour contre tours elle n'a pas
tout donné il y avait moyen de défendre
de manière un peu plus virulente
alors on va voir ah mince allait jouer
ce qui partait qui des cadres tous c'est
terrible à ces terribles c'est terrible
discipline
elles partent toutes celles des cadres
tous voila on veut les départage tout de
suite là on veut pas attendre les gars
donnez-nous les départage les a mis là
on est on veut pas attendre annoncé des
cas tout ça
en sueur quand même un mathieu cornette
s'il suit doigt dessus et là dans le
tchat
cadrin les gages concentrer sur le
recadrage quand même sympa d'avoir les
joueuses en caméras elles font une
petite pause
allez ça va partir
mathieu à pôle emploi
terrible ans pour mathieu quand même
ouais mais tu entraînes en traîne sahara
voir ce que ça donne parce que sarah va
réussir quand même à l'emporter ou pas
c'est loin d'être serein c'est loin
d'être sûr donc avant de partir en plus
ça
on va bientôt savoir on va bientôt
savoir les amis moi j'aimerais ouvrir je
vais ouvrir mon balcon
ah non il m'a encore des cadres et les
camions peu plus peut plus arrêter de
partir je vais ouvrir mon balcon
je vais rire mon balcon on va repartir
on va attendre et c'est rld et car
encore une fois
reste est un peu la faute du coach aussi
un
en tout cas nassara bien cadré
sarah qui est en train de checker son
carnet d adresses pour un nouveau coach
on me dit à l'oreillette que mur tu as
seraient dans la course senior tahiti à
faire ce tri mais après cette terrible
ouais ça va tu veux pas parler à mathieu
pendant la mi temps et elle a bien
raison non mathieu qui est même pas dans
le dans le chatt poursuivre pour suivre
ce à quoi s'est c'est incroyable c'est
incroyable les amis c'est tout
simplement un quoi voilà le sourire
sarah quand même ça va elle en rigole
pas le sourire à fond c'est déjà ça
après peut-être ban des fours matures
bon ça va partir ça va être marrant donc
deux parties les amis et en cas
d'égalité il y aura un armageddon en 5
contre 4 extraordinaire un finalement
finalement finalement on aura trouvé de
l'intérêt à cette journée à la toute fin
ça c'est de manière fortuite j'ai envie
de dire sourit elle soit elle sourit
vite fait un quand même ça doit dire
mathieu cornette ils se battent coach
c'est vraiment les mots qui devrait dit
en interview
my problème my problem is my smile
trainer certaines mathieu cornette well
known in den eynde chess milieu in
friends from colmar on le connaît mon
sahara qui repart dans son exactement la
même ouverture
allez on va voir en voir ce que ça donne
en espérant que ça donne mieux que tout
à leur bon alors là elle a changé il n'y
a pas il n'y a pas eu
il ya eu le détroit n'y a pas eu les
échanges comme tout à leur faire flouer
fin à peut-être mettre le pion cas tout
en déca tu sais pas comment ils comptent
jouer mais c'est clairement à c'est
clairement la joueuse américaine a
maintenant qui a l'ascendant
psychologique al elle prend des cinq ans
qu'est ce qu'elle va faire peut-être du
cavalier des quatre à elle s'était
gardée la casse pour le cavalier venir
jaillira prévert vers f5 temps elle fait
eu 4 puis on prend pions prend et ls
cavaliers prend mais il y avait sûrement
des dames des quatre intermédiaires à
l'écart et les promus 5la joueuses
iraniennes qui va peut-être mettre son
pied en g3 f4 nom elle fait d'un f3 elle
prépare tête des cavaliers des cinq je
sais pas volant mais allez le pion qui
part en g3 d'alger de f4 peut-être au
prochain ces dames en f3 qui est pas qui
est pas très bien placé qui est pas
idéal côté côté iranien le fou qui vit à
angers 2 qu'est-ce qui va qu'est ce qui
va se passer côté noir comment comment
progresser peut-être une tour qui
pourrait rentrer en d2 côté américain
c'est la dame qui vient en bécane la
dame revient à eux deux les noms et les
blancs pour le mans qui colmate les
cases peut-être mais le fou en d4 ça
vient clouer c'est difficile un point
pour sarah la dame qui est dans le
vis-à-vis de la tour le fouquet dans
dans le vide à vide
croyez quand même pas mal de pièces
blanches mal placé peut-être un coup
deux tours d un nom elle fâche 3d vite
les cavaliers g4 à long terme maintenant
des fous g61 peuvent être des points
intéressants ça redonne un peu de place
aux rois et ça permet éventuellement de
le fou h5 africa et 17 elle veut revenir
probablement vers la case eu cinq ou c5
elle fait foi cette maintenant elles
dégagent sont fous a laissé l'occasion
pour sarah jouer pour céder un f4 5
voilà avec un petit peu de un petit peu
d'ambition maintenant côté côté iranien
la dame qui par angers 4 ça a l'air
d'être assez bien joué elle menace
cavaliers dessin ou grosses menaces a un
côté blanca et d5 aidé à me ranger cette
matt irina qui a marqué un temps d'arrêt
et peut-être qu'il y ait des cinq quand
même
et foin f6 allez on y va peut-être côté
côté est côté sarah c'est peut-être le
moment d'envoyer un c'est du bullet non
elle fait cavalier à 4 elle va jouer un
peu de l'autre côté elle va s'en prendre
aux cavaliers sur cavaliers prend 1,4
elle veut quoi elle veut quoi sur quels
points 4 je ne sais pas les amis elle
veut fouquereau f6 elle veut [ __ ] un
f6 qu'elle prend 1,4 sous préfet si
c'est la partie tour 17 et dame prend 17
elle a complètement craqué irina haut
c'est incroyable ce qui vient de se
passer
irina oldham prendrait sept matches au
le craquage d'irina assez incroyable en
l'espace de deux coups elle a donné une
tour en 1 re es un matin d'un coup et
maintenant c'est la joueuse iranienne 1
qui renverse complètement la pression
est la plus besoin que d'une nulle pour
l'emporter
allez petit rock b6 to b cette c5 elle a
déjà fait tout à l'heure la côte à 100
contre 1 qui qui ne va peut-être pas
tomber un les amis puisqu'ils reina est
en train de se remettre dans le dur
allait peut-être un fouet fuite b6 est
ce un coup on part dans le schéma
qu'elle a joué tout à l'heure c'était
peut-être pas si mal à un moment de la
partie va juste falloir fermer le match
allait elle mêle fond assis cette fois
ci elle met la pression qui a aidé cet
ours et 8 c 5
c'est du simple c'est du dur c'est du
facile qu'on entend une ambulance au
loin pour venir chercher langlès pour
pour irina dépensé 4 ses prix le pion
qui prend en d4 et la tour c 8 qui va
mettre la pression sur les pions pendant
les pions bas qui comme on les appelle
les deux bas qui sont là la tour qui
vient ans et 8 damas huit simples ans
qu'elle a beaucoup aimé pendant tout le
match je pense qu'elle va rester dans
ses convictions non elle mais la dame
ans et 8 qui est b5 allez ça va échanger
elle va rejouer la case c6 avec
lecavalier mais peut-être qu'on peut
prendre prendre et mettre un cavalier en
d5 je pense que c'est l'ambiance
son côté sarah et cavaliers des cinq
maintenant qu'ils ferment la porte d'à
me 4g 6
le fou qui va revenir angers7 le pion au
sein qui va être sous pression la
colonne c'est qui est offerte à la
joueuse noir peut-être aussi le fou ces
cinq-là tour des huit là ça semble bien
se passer pour eux pour sarah finalement
qui n'a jamais été aussi proche de la
victoire dans le match aller proche de
fermer fermer la partie ici h4 jouer
peut-être g6 quand même le cavalier qui
peut aussi venir en c3 la tour en des 8
il ya beaucoup d'options il va falloir
faire son choix aller tour des huit
menaces cavaliers f4 maintenant le fou
qui vient à eux quatre pour attaquer le
cavalier peut-être maintenant le fameux
cavaliers ces trois noms elle prend ses
seins elle laisse la tour venir et
gagner un tempo el mellah d'amendé sept
alors maintenant comment est-ce que
irina va réagir dams et de menaces ou
prend 1,7 et maintenant h5 qui va partir
avec beaucoup d'ambition côté blanc il
va falloir faire quelque chose le pion
b5 qui va tomber
non c'est pas tomber yeux fous ces cinq
par non le pion qui est venu en g3 il ya
toujours pas de sacrifice en rangée 6
mais c'est sûr que ça ramait veille au
grain elle veut faire peut-être dame g5
crois j'essais tourache 8 et venir
switcher joué côté aura plus que 20
secondes
côté américain car à liège 4 échecs ça
va tomber mais le roi vient en f1 il n'y
a pas vraiment de suite à ça peut-être
3g 7 peut être un coup aussi peut-être
même cavalier trois échecs qui sait qui
c'est qui c'est c'est quand même bizarre
caillou trois échecs mais bon je propose
des coups comme je peux parce que bouger
ce cavalier pour aller faire tourner de
c'est intéressant faut-il encore réussir
à l'ami le cavalier e set elle veut
cavaliers f5 maintenant fou c'est un et
sur dame prochain qu'elle veut revenir
peut-être en b2 fou des cas très fort
c'est pour pas se faire mater en h suite
le fou qui revient en c1 là il semble qu
elle s'emmêle les pinceaux avec les
blancs la dame qui vit en g7 allait
peut-être fou g5
ouais ça ça ça envoie de partout le fou
qui va venir on a six dames f7 allez ça
va rentrer avec du dames c'est cette
peut-être dans le fou qui revient en d2
ouais c'est c'est un peu la foire
d'empoigné au projet 6 les amis hausse
est en train de partir fois cette
fois-çi ce fasciste c'est la dame qui
tombe pour sarah incroyable aplomb prend
2,3 s'est terminée au égalisation way
contre le cours du jeu
irina qui revient au score une nouvelle
fois et qui égalise dans ce match et ça
va partir en armageddon les amis c'est
incroyable un incroyable
c'est on ne sait pas vraiment comment ça
s'est passé mais tout d'un coup le match
le match s'est tourné en faveur de la
joueuse américaine
quel scénario auquel cas le scénario
incroyable les amis c'est incroyable ce
qui est en train de se passer
la dame qui est tombé et sarah sahara en
sueur vraiment sué à grosses gouttes
ouais on voit la caméra qu'elle est en
train d'accuser son coach un mathieu
cornet toile avec le sourire quand même
mais oui bien sûr mathieu est
responsable de cette défaite c'est un
peu les mots les mots qu'on retiendra de
sarah mon entraîneur va prendre un ban
des fins très clairement irina voilà qui
compatit qui j'ai déjà eu des
entraîneurs mauvais mais comme comme le
tien rarement est là on voit les deux
joueuses qui réfléchissent voilà green a
qui essaye de se rappeler de ces mauvais
coach mais elle a quand même du mal
quand on est tous en sueur voilà sahara
qui a qui est sain qui acquiesce qui
acquiesce mais mais ça arrive voilà on
va voir ça à partir pour la d un parti
donc il va y avoir un armageddon avec
cinq minutes pour les blancs 4000 pour
les noirs les blancs seront obligés de
gagner aujourd'hui on va au bout du
suspense les amis on va arriver à 4h02
de compétition sur la journée
extraordinaire quand on est tous en
apnée quand on est ok en train de perdre
son boulot cornetto qui en train de
disparaître de la liste des meilleurs
coaches cornetto qui n'est plus
sélectionneur de l'équipe de france
féminine après ce match qui perd son
poste
c'est difficile pour pour le français
qui a pris un crédit un il y à peu pour
s'acheter un appartement mais ça va
faire très très mal alors sahara qui a
les noirs qui doit faire nul ça va être
difficile il n'y a pas énormément de nul
dans ce match
encore des taux qui valent à pôle emploi
donc elle joue est indienne échange le
répertoire d'ailleurs pour cette partie
décisive à la bien compris que la prépa
du coach n'était pas la bonne et elle
décide elle décide de changer
ouais ça joue sajou les manoeuvres du de
côté avec une structure semi ruiz est ce
qu'un côté est côté sarah qui voilà qui
revient aux fondamentaux
quand les taux qui perd son titre de gm
heureusement encore des histoires qui
pourra le coach français qui pourra
compter sur l'extra à voir avec le
streamer france est exactement
masterclass incompréhensible exactement
sur ses meilleures parties qui sont qui
sont pas si belle que ça finalement
soyons soyons réalistes quand on est
vendeur deux vendeurs de chouchous à la
plage avec la petite cloche choo choo
choo choo cornet doit être recyclé
allez on va voir ce qui va se passer
dans cette partie le fourbe et celle de
sarah pas très bien mais peut-être db5
sont envisageables un peu à la bad en
basset c1 c'est un genre de benoni donc
forcément bessin qui va partir un jour
ou l'autre
peut-être maintenant 1 alors c'est west
indienne jusqu'à 10 aces mais ça peut ça
peut être une structure destin diane
benko est indienne
là c'est une ouest spatiale flambé cette
donc assis ça veut jouer b 5 à 4 kills
en empêche
dan 17 ça va ça va être très chaud là
pour pour sarah qui pourraient se faire
surprendre les amis ce cas prendre le
fou alors elle aurait pu c'est de mettre
la dame aurait d'ailleurs ce que
j'allais dire et et 10 et le fouet la
carélie 17
elle veut jouer ces 4 au 6 allée saraki
qui fait le taf
ces quatre dames c'est cette baie dams
dams et 4 dames ces cinq baies 5 alors
qu'il n'y a pas de rage ou de tendances
et partie dans cette arnaque et dont
c'est du 5 contre 4 sec et donc il va
falloir faire attention quand même
irina qui a qui se fait déjà rage qui se
rattrape déjà à la pendule aller le la
tour en huit lecavalier angers 6
peut-être l'autre en 17 5 à 4 ça peut
être des cas ce qu'ils visent mais on
voit se fout c'est 8 qui est sensible le
moindre problème
michal très sensible se fout on voit qui
peut pas pas trop d'endroits à viser
très sensible à voir ce qui va se passer
peut-être du fou mais fou 17 tombes et
8b 5 à l'écaillé g6 à l'attack 4s que
est ce qu est ce que ça m'a un petit
coup de de pression là irina qui marque
un temps d'arrêt après kg 6 4 est
attaqué il va falloir le défendre côté
américain
peut-être juste un coup comme dame c21
paraît logique mais le fou qui va
peut-être revenir en bessette et qui
sait où obtenant 17 db5 il peut y avoir
une une surpression sur le cavalier ces
trois là qui peut être pressurisée
cavale et prend 1,4 aussi on n'en a pas
parlé mais qu'à rallier prend quel point
f5 ça peut ça peut être une idée un pur
pour les noirs sarah qui joue tomber 8
oui tu vas jouer fou 17 b5 et qui va
dire aux cavaliers coco il va falloir
défendre en 4 et b5
c'est peut-être pas si simple que ça
plus de deux minutes trente pour irina
crusher in accroche qui à mon avis là se
retrouve derrière un dans cette
armageddon maintenant parce que parce
que le temps était rattrapé la position
est pas si écrasante que ça elle doit
elle doit absolument l'emporter
on imagine un coup comme fou 17la côté
iranien on imagine sahara qui calcule
cavale et prend 4.456 aurait fait dams
est elle augmente la pression sur le
pion aux 4 qui doit être défendu à mon
avis par food et 3 c'est un peu la seule
option
elle veut elle veut claquer un b 5 dans
le dans le bon timing
je me dis qu'à faire fou 17 d'abord
voilà c'est exactement ça sur f5 elle
reprend la case de 5 avec le cavalier
c'est bueno et donc à bessens qui arrive
au prochain plus que deux minutes un
côté rinne a crush faut pas oublier les
amis qu'il ne reste il n'y a plus il ya
plus le rajout de temps là pour pour les
joueuses c'est plus possible de
récupérer du temps cc du cdu sec et la
b5 qui parole à joueuses iraniennes à
qui prend le qui prend le dessus
maintenant c'est le plus haut 4 qui va
se retrouver sous pression sur b katia
c4i ab4 qui menace ouais ça à qui a
changé d'ouverture et finalement c'est
peut-être ce qui va lui rapporter le
point de la victoire dans ce match les
noirs qui menace de mettre le pion en b
4 et d'enchaîner par un petit cavalier e
4 sympathique alors cavaliers f5 ça à
partir en poupe en extinction pro f 5 et
le cavalier qui va se replacer
tranquillement en fuite et les blancs
qui vont avoir une structure de pions
complètement délabrée mais vettel peut
être joué
sur un cavalier prend b5 par la suite
c'est pour ça que sarah ne prend pas en
bref 5 avait baissé incomprise
à la fin de la variante et el mellah
d'amendé 8 avec l'idée de jouer du bk de
prendre après de faire cavalier cette
cavale et prend des cinq plus qu'une
minute trente pour irina crush irin
accroche son grand danger les amis elle
est à l'agonie en après b4 fou prend un
cavalier ou 7 ça semble ça semble
complètement tourné pour pour sarah
sahara qui attaquent le cavalier c3 le
fou qui va prendre f5 le cavalier e set
ouais ça fait très très mal la ire une
accroche on voit sur son visage sur son
faciès le lançant la défaite à da qui
arrive le cavalier qui va prendre en d5
elle a laissé passer sa chance irina
crush lakota sont contraints qui va qui
va pas tomber aujourd'hui
ouais ça va pas tomber les amis le
cavalier qui va qui va prendre qu'il va
jaillir sur trois la colonne avec tours
8 tours sète tours 8 ça va doubler et
c'est un vrai pions plus maintenant pour
la joueuse iranienne qui a rallié prend
des 5 c'est cadeau alors peut-être
maintenant échanger mettre le cavalier
en c3 ça semble faire très très mal déjà
cavaliers g4 fait mal
allez faut garder le rythme côté sarah
lecavalier qui rentrent en c3 les pions
qui vont avancer la d'amendés 6
allez un petit fou ces six pour avoir
des idées sur dams et 8 2 tours 8 échecs
mais la d5 et d'anne decis semble juste
finir la partie et s'est jouée par sarah
s'est jouée par sarah qui va qui va
mettre la d'amendés 6 et qui va faire
extrêmement mal à son adversaire la dame
des six menace le fou le pion au f4 qui
en l'air fou fou ou huit qui ne menace
rien et damco f4 qui va tomber les pions
là qui vont tomber les uns après les
autres
côté irina lecavalier qui peut rejaillir
henri iv à tout moment pour attaquer le
fou 1,8
il y aura du cavaliere deux échecs qui
traînera au passage où la carène leucate
est vraiment une grosse menace
il semble qu irina soit quelques
encablures de l'abandon aux cavaliers 4
qu'est ce qui se passe sur camaïeu 4 ici
c'est la question qu'on se pose côté
commentateurs car le 4 semble semble
juste gagner un menace cavaliers de haut
mais l'ordinateur donne foot pro f 16
qui reviendrait dans la partie ouais
c'est terrible fou prend f7 fo prend f7
les amis ouais c'est la seule chance
oh c'est pas fini les amis c'est pas
fini il faut prendre ces trois points
cette dame prend
des cinq et on prend 2,4 elle est encore
dans la partie la joueuse
la joueuse américaine il faut le voir la
foule jouer vite ouais dame prend des 5
c dans le mauvais sens tout reprend 1,8
et c'est fini well as pas vu on voit sur
son visage elle n'a pas vu elle a craqué
physiquement on est c'est la fringale
c'est la fringale et alors là cavalier
g3 qui avait lieu de avec le père pète
ce serait très très vite jouée côté
français là je te dire il n'y a pas
d'hésitation on prend la null null gagne
aurait prend pas là nul incroyable
incroyable les amis de pas prendre là
nul mais iliad avait faim d'alger un mât
attend d'eux et ça va gagner et ceir y
est c'est sarah qui l'emportent
finalement elle et elle est sortie de la
préparation
elle a arrêté de jouer après pas de
quand on est haut et est là elle est
rentrée dans les petites vestes indienne
et c'est ce qui a fait tourner le match
en sa faveur
belle belle réaction côté côté sarah qui
prend qui prend la bonne décision
finalement et qui en changeant
d'ouverture réussi riches à mettre la
partie voilà le sourire elle sera de
retour demain pour faire mieux
qu'aujourd'hui
sinon elle remportera pas le match mais
bon elle est passée elle est en quarts
de finale et parfois ça peut ça peut
détendre comme ça de gagner un match
dans l'est dans les derniers instants ça
peut ça peut redonner confiance en tous
cas bravo à elle pour sa victoire
donc elle remporte le match 7 6 au bout
du au bout du suspense causé new qui a
gagné facilement 7,3 à l'un ou chez nina
9,4 arica 11,2 et on va voir du coup les
quarts de finale avec kosteniuk koné
roues joli match
arica contre uni fans c'est aussi une
belle affiche katia l'agglo contre ou
chez nina très belle affiche aussi et
jouanne jun qui affrontera sahara pour
pour le match qu'on suivra en deuxième
partie de journée
de très belles affiches demain donc
soyez au rendez vous à 14h30
il y aura il y aura des beaux matchs
demain ça va être sympa et donc on se
retrouve on se retrouve pour pour ça et
puis nous on se retrouve un peu plus
tard ce soir j'avais prévu de faire le
live face
finir avec cinq heures et demi j'avais
prévu de faire le live à cette heure
aujourd'hui pour les blitz on va voir et
de toute façon la master class de fab à
8h30
je vous dis merci à tous d'avoir suivi
et et à demain